five there's Queenie a fight but then I
guess you just have Bishop d2 and so
what yeah yeah then you're like yeah
been your trouble
so there we go looking for something
with 96 and 96 oh we seize it unless I
would now I called it six in Queen b6
made Anish oh my god a nice smile
[Music]
I'm not sure we've ever had two players
that are more ready for this match than
Amish Gary and Levon Aronian they're
excited they're having fun with each
other Eric my co-host mr. Eric Hanson
mr. Jeff brought himself joining us from
the legendary gasser Sarah wants to do I
can tell from the bookshelf behind you
yes how ready are you for this match
here as we move into the quarterfinals
of the speed chess championship well I
think I get a bit of a reading boost
just by being in this room surrounded by
like Class C chess literature but two of
the hottest players of the year I'm very
very ready for this yeah we are
obviously greatly anticipating this we
everyone who's been following the event
knows that both of these guys moved on
and exciting matches but slightly
different paths if you want to talk
about the fact that Anish had a a much
closer match in his first round opponent
with a chakra arm of Europe but LaVon
really really took care of his opponent
in kind of a shocking fashion beating
the world championship challenger
Fabiano Caruana by a score of twenty and
a half to six and a half how surprised
were you by lavon's dominant performance
there or maybe not at all and what do
you expect to see as these to throw down
here in the quarterfinals I was I was
more surprised I should say by probably
fab ease performance Levon when he's
feeling good playing aggressive and
we've seen it time and time again he can
you can really put up some pretty
remarkable performances so I just feel
like he's in a good place right now and
yeah not happens not a lot of things
surprised me well according to our
smarter chef's pregame predictions based
on these guys performances we we tend to
see LaVon as a statistical favorite I'm
not sure I really buy it to be that big
of an edge although I guess on paper and
by his rating as LaVon was pointing out
to his opponent I'm having some fun with
him before before we went live here he's
he's higher rated than Anish I'm both
blitz and bullet on chest comm so if
that has to do with anything but
regardless of what happens in today's
match want to remind everybody while we
have your attention remember that we now
have a couple big break before our final
week of the quarter finals that'll be
Wesley so versus vid at Gujarati taking
place on Tuesday October 9th and then
course we have Hikaru Nakamura versus
Maxime vache the graph to bring the
quarterfinals to a close then we will
have a a month break as you and I Erik
spend spent a lot of time covering
another event a different event maybe
not as big as the speech has
championship but the World Championship
in November and then we'll have the
finals in the first week in a December
so I think we're pretty much ready to
rock the players are ready I want to
remind everybody and there we go we have
our first subscription one remind
everybody about the raffle that's going
on remember all merch purchase today in
our store goes directly to the prize
fund for the players so if you want a
sexy mug like this Eric I gotta get you
one of these maybe you should enter the
raffle I died well I will what do I have
to do just just type raffle oh okay
there you go all that goes directly to
the players but I think we're ready to
rock the players are ready and I'm gonna
give my team to go ahead Eric good to
have you here man I'm excited it's good
to be here no I mean this is one of the
matchups that I was looking forward to
and I honestly Danny if you asked me I
would put up close to 5050 I feel like
on each is always a guy who can surprise
people online he doesn't play publicly
very often right but he's always you
know he's a guy who who's practicing
somewhere yep he's got something up to
Celine you and I know actually you told
me off the record last year how
disappointed he was about losing to
Wesley so in the first round that he
really did prepare for that match he
wanted it and this year that showed when
he beat Mahmoud Yerevan so I agree with
you I think regardless of what the stats
say I put this match much closer to 5050
I think the previous result of Anish
maybe losing last year affects those
stats a little bit more than it should
but okay I'm not a statistician I'm just
here to commentate on chest like you and
we have our first first awkward opening
of the day super close center what's
going on here it's like a blitz opening
you give white a bunch of space but what
has to be a little careful but it's just
an easy easy opening and you know your
moves you know your setup and you're
just asking on each to be aggressive
maybe it's you know they're playing some
mind games with each other maybe because
on each is known as as a very principled
opening player so he feels compelled to
punish this slightly dubious variation
yeah well already it feels like Weis
play is just gonna be supernatural f4 is
coming off the kingside will be opening
up and well you ya know f4 f4 is
definitely one of the ideas blocks night
on d7 is hoping that you know for an e5
square and that's one thing that f4
would allow so Anya she's probably gonna
take a little bit more time maybe rookie
you want maybe h3 before committing to
f4 but it's definitely in the cards h3
stops Knight to g4 I think now maybe we
see a for no reason not to no reason not
to f4 f4 looks good you can still
prepare it but why not go out for it's
interesting Dani momager off played some
you could say dubious lines against on
each I think people are maybe erroneous
looking to one-up them and say you know
I can play I can give you right give you
everything you want and still beat you
know that was that was one of the most
fun aspects of that match which I forgot
about thank you for reminding me that
those of you who may have may have
missed the Geary vs. Mahmud yard match
you might want to might want to check it
out there were some trolling openings
going on that ultimately got mom and are
back in the match so maybe Aleman is
just trying to say I can play anything
against you right I guess if you win a
game like this as black it's a good
start to the match yeah okay now I'm not
predicting a great result for black here
this is the kind of position as you said
where white can play patiently on both
sides of the board b4f for big space
advantage other than the fact that it's
blitz it's hard to like black at all yep
no it's that you're completely right
it's just blacks just reacting to white
there's no you're not you can consider
f5 is black then whites gonna counter
with that for at some point and King on
each it probably looks a little more
vulnerable than the King on each one but
time will tell
interesting there so he's going away
from the idea of f4 by inviting a
potential trade and I guess what he's
saying is that the F file followed by
the idea of even just doubling pretty
straightforward White's still will have
a pretty good attack on the King's Own
g4 yeah g4 looks very natural here maybe
rook f3 double rooks on the F file maybe
put up on two
- g5s great okay well this is this is
some you know some players don't mind
playing really passively LaVon is a
fairly active player so this surprises
me more than normal right because of his
what he thrives in however it's just the
first game and things can definitely
change yeah
well the the interesting thing will be
if this matches 55 he's now 55 right get
the dark scores off them dark Spurs off
the board trades are good but I was
gonna say if this is a match that sees
more openings like this or more eventual
transition into some mainline theorem
which may depend on how close the
matches and and what the players want to
do right okay but this is a good trade
for blackest even though this Bishop on
e7 was serving some defensive purposes
now getting the dark squares off the off
the board for white that helps blacks
defense right for sure
I mean Black has a Benoni pawn structure
but the pond d6 can't be attacked right
now so that's not so bad
and Iranians managed to trade off two
pieces right now really what I'm
thinking about is was it a good idea to
accept the gg pawns brownish that was a
that was a risky decision I'm not sure
I'm a fan of it based on this resulting
position right and definitely a
different transition than what we were
anticipating where white could have shot
at four well here he goes g4 I'm
expecting he's gonna shift the rooks the
F file again which maybe rook B to rook
F to bring that Knight to f3 I just
don't see where else you can break
things open Danny right Knight up three
G files no I tend to agree the more we
look at it the more it feels like kind
of an awkward decision to take for a
white because even if you get the dream
position you're talking about get the
rooks doubled on the F file then what
right where's the where's the knockout
yeah it's gonna be combined with the
move g5 at some point and then you're at
least fighting for the f6 square and and
maybe opening up the Kings side but uh
Nisha isn't going going in that
direction g5 again if you if you
continue trading then you might be in a
position where your pawns on the light
squares and maybe black ends up with
more targets
you see for you four pieces come off the
more this Bishop on d3 doesn't look
great in the more the black Bishop yeah
I really like g5 there and if age five
some sort of net age for a super
aggressive approach but I mean should
probably wouldn't play that he goes for
it now with g5 and he goes for now but I
want to look back on that one night each
fortnight f5 and just sack apiece it's
not quite sound but the idea is
definitely in the air to get the double
will to get the pawns on i-5 and g5 and
to maybe play off six right you might be
thinking about it yeah it might be
something to try especially as time
pressure ensues but as we look at the
clock white is uh has taken a lot more
time than black so just might having a
world I know the opening lavon's played
a lot faster ya know lavon's position I
was just completely fine I mean you
should trade it off pretty willingly
here and there's just no no breakthrough
for for white yeah and you uh as you
foreshadow the the pawn on c4 and the
light squares might be might be a
problem for white so uh Nicias Queen
quindi maybe and eventually have six
okay Quinn a5 is an annoying move you
put Quinn D and I might have Queen 85 in
some lines maybe not immediately but
right something something is considering
no no he can play Bishop c8 on 2005 and
the Queen actually Gore's the a7 pollen
yes and after Bishop senior three and
Knight takes d5 but he might like your
idea still the Queen on c7 guards a7 and
maybe wants to go to e7 mm-hmm well I
definitely think this is fairly equal
but that has the favor LaVon at the
minute extra on the clock also depends
what with the mentality vanishes does he
feel like he's lost the punish LaVon or
if he's okay with you quality then I
think it's his best interest to actually
steer this towards an equal endgame yeah
because LaVon will punish him if he gets
the one time you know he's waiting
waiting to go Frannie when he's a long
time well one of the things we predicted
about these players based on their
performances that LaVon would be a
better bullet player so we'll see how
that stacks up but again I agree
to you that hard to say when you don't
see these guys playing too much so who
knows but LaVon really did take
advantage of Fabiano Caruana in the
bullet portion and so we'll see how that
shakes out and in about a couple hours
but okay so now they're just just
playing tickle here I don't think either
side yeah I mean you can consider at
some point playing f6 is black maybe
with a net on g8 it's gonna play off six
but I'm not sure who that helps Oh Queen
trade yeah Queen c7 Queen 85 is an idea
if you don't want to drink Queens
although I expect onion shall put the
Queen back on c3 that's the case we have
Queen c7 here maybe try to get Quinn a
five truck if you can get in on the dark
squares you're happy but that requires
getting rid of the g5 pawn because
otherwise that on g8 just doesn't have
any room but the Queen trade is that
really favored white I mean it feels
like black girls although I will Tammany
yeah I think this is risk free as well
but in time trouble I use that's a bit
easier furnish to handle then with with
the Queen's off I guess he wants to
bring the King to a5 yeah I guess the
main thing is even if you get the King
be a five and try to play Bishop a4 y
can still sit tight black wants to
either get this Bishop on the back side
of the pawn structure everyone where it
can kind of target things like c4 she to
but if white doesn't allow the the entry
of the bishop then probably should still
be a peaceful result yep maybe King a6
Knight b6 so Knight check then k x4 well
I think that's gonna happen
yeah but it's though I don't see
anything clear you're
still looks like it's a close to a draw
there but LaVon LaVon has has a few
different cards to play and he can
rotate between the King said on the
Queen side pretty effortlessly here so
why not play on all the Bishop cf6
the bishop gets behind the pollen chain
but Bishop g2 yeah doesn't do too much
but okay he's done it f6 that forces
LaVon I need to take so he's not stuck
with the g5 weakness the king can get in
well there's definitely some danger here
what's the what's the winning plan for
black if we could just put our pieces
where we want let's uh I don't see one
yeah I mean even if the Black Knight
gets to be too maybe where it hits c4
there's just no real way with the knight
on D 2 and the bishop on this F 1 c4
diagonal it just looks like it's just
stuck right yeah you need the King to be
part of it two pieces against two pieces
you can target the weaknesses but if the
King on h6 can't get into the game then
I don't see how you actually get it in
there
now each four is a bit of a target so
maybe LaVon is gonna try to put a net on
g6 and Bishop on g4 yeah oh oh did not
see that Danny Knight see for dishes a6
check the King on saw it either
that could be a game right there he was
gonna say that it looked unnatural on d3
cuz why not you through but I didn't see
this tactic right it's almost so basic
okay so anyways it's not necessarily
over what if I put my net on g5 and I
just shuffle back and forth then I don't
see any way for you get your King in so
you're gonna have to bring a king over
to the green side yeah and each might
get lower here that despite that just
like that blunder there may not be a way
for black to get the king in which
mm-hmm the white pawn on e4 the white
pawn on h4 lucky blockade on the King
side and perhaps no way for Bishop d3
then you're gonna bring the King over to
a5
right nice nice setup they're quickly
recognizing the knight is ideal on c3
where it holds both a4 and the eclip on
looks like a good setup for uh niche
there that's right
III controls b49 controls every square
it's on a dark square so it can't be
booted off if the King for white was far
away you could try to play c4 king c5
Kennedy for ya block right now an ish is
gonna okay there we go
King seeking c5 but okay you get King c5
I stick my King on e3 I guess eventually
the bishop can sort of use the triple
step sort of a circus wanna perhaps
targeting the light square pawn and
making this knight move from c3
we'll see if the knight has to move from
c3 but what do you do after that
so let's say I play 92 now you need a
useful move well I was surprised by the
bishop coming be c3 c3 smoking c4 c4
there we go yes is this enough it's the
only chance now you've got a knight
coming to f5 that's true
and hitting dis it's gonna go down five
no matter what right because the bishop
can contest it oh no right now with the
King on c4 Knight f5 I can take and take
on d5 yeah both brothers are passing I
was with in king c5 maybe okay John
Mercer has settled in though LaVon gonna
use the last bit of time advantage he
has to see if there's a chance to win
both players want to pass yet mutual
serve the King on c4 needs to watch out
for Knight f5 yeah Knight f5 so you can
play king c5 but then king c3 king c3
should be enough right to hold tight
yep king c3 now
so if Knight a5 Bishop back to g6 I'd
say for the most part some pretty the
night went to f5 and black took a four
white would have played Knight to g7
right but then Bishop d1 so now now the
Kings getting in though King to d4 I
guess then no no Knight a5 truck I have
to go right back to c5 yeah okay so
likely despite our our our anticipation
greatly anticipating a decisive result
instead Anish holds the worse ending and
and we move on I'd say I think both
players can be happy about that game
only because they got to play a full
game and get rid of maybe some of the
nerves without giving up a point but
LaVon getting a good position is black
there it's gonna be something he's yeah
Anish can and can't allow as the match
goes on to not punish an opening like
that yep so 2020 2018 LaVon playing lots
of e4
okay so pretty symmetrical symmetrical
blocks gonna well on ish is one of the
top petrov players in the world if not
well now that Fabiana was playing it's
debatable but uh Nisha has been playing
this since he was like yeah young boy
and symmetrical positions are his bread
and butter young as they would say yes
well what what what is it that you think
had Leblon transition to mori for as
part of his repertoire just just bored
and wants more stuff or more stuff to
play I've always had the impression
LaVon is a big chest lover yeah as a
person and as a chest lover means to
have more ways to explore the game
master d4 I play that most of my life
yeah and why not try you for because you
know he's stolen his prime and he's
still spending time on chest but it's a
new unchartered territory at least
playing it with the top players and I
feel like he's that sort of guys like to
give the game you know some of the
respect I should be you know mastering
you for also just it's a good thing if
you can do it in a we're gonna say was
that a blunder or was that on purpose
they're trying I would say because
obviously white couldn't take with the
Queen everyone cuz because background
check so c6 or Queen D it's gonna
before you bring the Queen back you just
defense yourself yeah I'm box gonna play
for this pawn structure whether that's
c6 here or Queen India
yep the only reason why I'm doing about
Queen d8 is I'm thinking White's gonna
play Queen f4 1 and rook e1 and bring
the Queen over to eat of g2 or h3 so my
Queen honey it might be feel a little
uncomfortable with all these pieces
covering the e-file Queen up one is that
so it's gonna be very it's gonna be an
imbalance game based on the two bishops
and the worst pawn structure for white
and it's a typical way they would want
to use what happens here on your Kings
side put the King on h1 get a rook to
the G file so if the bishop hair gets
loose on the Kings side then you won't
be regretting the double plans at all
yeah I liked
yeah what's a similar idea if g6 like
I'm wondering if that Nets going to h6
or not if g6 probably managed six check
and then they talk to G for you
okay Knight comes to h5 no white might
just save the bishop pair with Bishop e5
first Bishop g5 first cuz well you don't
really have to worry about Queen h4
right the night under five is guarding
it I just wanna provoke f6 yeah because
that would be really bad but if I don't
play out six where's my queen going
right Queenie runs into rook you won
Queen where else so now but you might be
the first Knight d7 of sex right yeah
six bring the Queen to d7 huh and play
rook yeah yeah the Knights protect each
other I think and get away with it Queen
d7 and rookie year but why still a
little initiative yeah still a little
awkward for black you got to get to the
e-file quickly
Queen d7 you have to be careful at some
point the white tries to get the Queen
to g5 no immediate threat something like
Bishop takes f6 and Queen g5 is is
lurking King f8 is the move if you give
away drugs for Bishop then I'm
comfortable though I'm not King yeah
that's a good light our confusion about
to be a little careful yeah Rick I've
make sense
rook e1 rook e8 why it's just gonna
leave that rook there and hope to entice
the trade yeah and open things up even
more
lavon's putting some pressure on here
Anish has not managed to trade off
pieces which in favor is better pawn
structure and now he's got to make a
hard decision because he's almost
running out of moves no time pressure
yet for either players so both sides
pretty comfortable I guess and what what
this has been all about is white over
you're gonna gonna play f4 to reinforce
the route there you just don't want to
give a target for black's knight on h5
that's right I think that's one of it
also f4 I have to worry about net g4 and
some lines I think I'm gonna wait for
now because another problem would have
for is it commits my Bishop to the Kings
side it's trapped I can't go back over
to e3 or d2 so it can easily be pushed
away without h6 okay so now what black
to move well every single move has a
consequence that was profound like like
so you should teach chess for a living
that was profound well I don't know
what's on lavon's t-shirts but maybe
it's something like that his tee shirt
that he's wearing there's some text
there every every move in life as a
consequence you know I could know but
I'll see all jokes aside Eric's right g6
obviously weakens the knight on f6 and
the dark squares h6 opens up tactics
against the pawn and as Eric said taking
me five White's gonna capture back
probably just with the D pawn and then
and then have a majority so so as
profound as it was it's also practically
applicable practically appropriate here
that black is sorta just wants to sit
tight honest rookie six is a good move
this attack he took a lot of time on
that I think you're gonna have to pick
up his place he 6k four doesn't change
the structure of the position
so you could get away with a move like
c6 or a six instead he's trying to be a
bit more direct and see how you can
trade something off that's a good move
Dani because Bishop f5 is on the horizon
forcing that rook otherwise doubles the
pawns although I could probably take
with Pope on but I think Oh a 25 he's
gonna take on you five now I think he's
gonna take on e5 forcing D takes e5 that
might be fine for white but otherwise if
you don't do that I'm playing f4 uh-huh
next f4 back with the F pawn Levon slow
honza he's good he's grinding it's I
mean so Bishop e5 is a cert Bishop g7
and yeah Bishop e7 is gonna force wait
to make the trade he doesn't want to on
e6 right but even that trades not the
end of the world because white will have
the two bishops in the endgame and you
start to consider moves like a five here
if you're white just to open up that a
four square for the bishop and the
potential of knowing the endgame is
gonna need you to have play on both
sides if you're trying to win so a
question is Levon looking for something
concrete here or he's content with
trying to improve the position because
Bishop g7 is coming okay Bishop g7 he's
gonna play rook back to you three
doesn't want to trade yeah Hani's that's
the only way I can rationalize that now
b3 oh no he backs up the bishop was
anticipating him just sitting on the
Queen side with the bishop no longer
worrying about attacks like f6 at some
point y can maybe be a little more
aggressive play a four and a five no
just trade the rooks you have an endgame
up a minute and a half
LaVon he's gonna trade Queens I think
honey is still gonna be happy you just
have less fun you know there's lost
chances to make a big blunder and agree
just blended with the Queen's Peniche
off the busting out the patented head
Bob saying he's relaxed
I'm leaning towards queen d1 here and
just plain kimchi - as a follow-up Dani
and just at some point I like the move
f4 f5 yep trying to sacrifice that pawn
but we can blacks King side but yeah
Queen d1 in King g2 is what I'd be going
for it seems to make sense to keep the
Queen's on the board if you sure if
you're still trying to make weaknesses
right you said f4 5 if the Queen's are
on the board white can follow up between
h5 at some point and maybe you still
have outside chances of an attack on the
Kings side mm-hmm you may not play out
for quite yet because be 300 - that's
normal but at b3 if you play out for the
night might go back to d6 and then jump
into you 409 take his time on playing b3
it's just whether you can find some
other useful most besides b3 k h6
lavon's definitely calling the shots
here honey she's just gotta maintain I'd
say keep about 10 seconds on the clock
and try not to commit himself to
anything that requires much calculation
and right now he's doing that and he's
just waiting for LaVon if the long plays
b3 or if you plays f4 and we've seen
time pressure already for vernisha in
both games area because there's
something you think will continue here
LaVon just that much faster
I think LaVon is a faster player in
general except maybe in bullet I nation
and bullet an inch seems to let go and
he plays quickly he just has bullet mode
but otherwise I think LaVon I think
lavon's a little bit of the faster
player what comes through busting on
those very solid for Park but I'm just
yeah I mean we've already seen him hold
an endgame once right being worse and
down on time so anisha's trying to do
that again but I like White's chances if
he gives the Queens on the home I like
that yet play play you want to play a
four but it opens up a four so you're
just finding it short you should have
four should be thought maybe five yeah
that's right there should be five I'd
like to play f4 f5 but I'm only
I'm gonna do that later on yeah okay but
now you've been do step six oh that's oh
that's clever night of sevens clever
Bishop by five is a cool-looking move
here but it doesn't do anything if I
don't take the bishop dish 56 that
four-foot can be played now because
there's all night coming d4 I got set up
for the Vaughan the bishops cover you
want e 2 e 3 4 and the Queen maybe goes
to f3 and or e3 ok that's fine
interesting why now why now trade cleans
just cuz it's outer space Wiener go to
have VII likely have 3 in ya going
should go back to 3 that's that seems
out well ok he's gonna allow the dark
squares to close up but now now this has
- oh I didn't see Queenie 6 though so
take 98 Bishop f5 King f8 King f8 here
you can give up each pawn for the e pawn
and then d4 is actually gonna be a bit
of a target something feels like it's
gone wrong here for LaVon suddenly yes
yes Kim you 7 followed by 96 I don't see
how you stop that right so you play
Bishop maybe 587 this is key and you may
just have to train on d8 and instead I
want to draw obstacle Bishop's on the
good side of it you King King up I was
wondering if okay he just sits tight
even here the bishop can shuffle to be
to hitting deflower preventing looking
for ever getting loose this is the draw
could be it wrong
LaVon taking a few seconds there perhaps
to try to come up with a creative idea
but with no time on the clock like on a
settle and they offer and they do so
patterns we've seen Anish be worse twice
but hold twice despite time pressure
right and being on the the worst end of
things in an endgame so not where you
would want to be really if you're an h2
consistently because you'd like to think
the more you're in bad positions under
time pressure it's not a good recipe but
gotta give got to given you some
defensive credit right for sticking with
it and being resourceful
for sure if you can
you can maintain this pace then get on
him because it's definitely tiring
suffering like that but I think that
last King was fairly well played like
there was never a strong evaluation and
as a as opposed to the first game and by
both sides really I mean Lavoie machine
but but an ish you know found the right
maneuvers at the right time yes it's the
type of draw that I'm a lot more okay
with right right and chassis at the
Costco's draws but right when the
players are are there's a clash of style
so you're not Greg Shahadah you're not
dogmatically against every draw no just
just the quick ones just the quick ones
right well yeah
fighting chest despite starting out with
two draws the anti of what we had on
Tuesday with grishnack and Duda for
those of you that somehow miss one of
the most amazing matches ever we had I
was we had no draws until bullet did you
see that it was it didn't say there was
called decisive results until the bullet
portion just incredible Danny I made a
big blunder I booked a flight at the
same fights
aníbal and you know what I also slept on
Duda just before the whole speech as his
championship started in terms of speech
s now he's my like my father's own he's
almost my favorite player in the field I
know right I feel like every note on us
how can you how can you not love the mom
coming out giving him a kiss on the
cheek against his will it was just great
do you think you'd feel pretty bad if
you lost to a player and then well
playing juniors are probably Hopkins but
like I've been you see who lives in his
mom's basement yes I lose to players
like that all the time but shout out
real quick to everybody in the chat
liquid egg product with some bits we saw
Scarlett Evans throw some bits chess Bay
all of our mods think - you just want
everyone to know that we see you we love
you both chess TV and chess calm and all
2,300 of you with us right now
hopefully you're with us all day and
thanks for being here remember enter the
raffle merge merge contest I feel like
I'm supposed to say that they told me
hey feature the mug and save merch and I
said okay I'll do what I'm told
no brothels are good free stuff is
always good
I'm pulling the the late-night shows
right now Eric where you have the cup
and you pretend that it's coffee but
it's just water inside you know is that
out lane I chose work or is it this is
water or is it even stronger often often
it's water often it's okay okay is that
alright I feel like a lane I'd show
anything could be in there well on this
year has a good position Danny I can say
that and unlike Game one of this match
he hasn't treated everything off blocks
pieces look a little bit awkward and it
revolves around whether white can break
through with d5 or something in the
center at some point because almost all
these pieces are geared up for for that
breakthrough yeah here here White's a
little bit better but in each was a
little bit better to start the last game
to Bishop g5 trying to trade off the
less active minor piece but at a risk
here because if you trade on g5 and play
e5 doesn't white have a new home on d6
for a knight mm-hmm although okay I
guess you can risk I would consider
taking and playing e5 in a million 94-94
not just the d6 query point out but
actually the g5 square I don't know how
black is gonna defend the g5 square but
besides the Queen but if only the Queen
can defend why can't I put my knight on
e4 and bring my Queen over Danny to g4
h5 I love that idea yeah but you can
still at some point bring the Queen over
to age five yeah and I like white no
this this looks like a deaf definitely
uh would you consider Knight c5 here
just to get the rook liver you don't
want to trade here when your opponent
has less I want to see because the 97 is
blocking the rook on Dida into the
knight moves right I put my net on c5
and feels feeling pretty happy about
okay yeah great point I almost liked the
idea that we said you were suggesting
with with e5 and the knight coming into
e4 here because you're aggressive switch
of the queen to the king side could be
really timely while black doesn't have
any minors over there to defend but
maybe an inch is like you know what I
should keep more pieces on the board and
I don't blame him for that thought but
yeah he has a few options there for the
first time we see a niche with a small
time advantage as we head under three
minutes so not much but noticeable in
the sense that Anisha has been down
significant
most games Queen comes to see
three-headed 2d - just cut it - did -
you can always play p3 now to be
enforced upon but yeah I like I like
just inching her way over here I'm just
trying to figure out where he's putting
that night on YouTube because so the
Queen here is gonna go to e3 right now
or maybe I for right away ah the Queen's
okay on the default because Queen e3 and
f4 or a4 right now asking an immediate
question and he's done it because
there's no other way for black to defend
g5 the Queen's I don't play at night he
takes followed by Queen to either III or
f2 if he takes to the D night then
there's something more specific that he
has in mind
oh whoa whoa that's so I woke up I tell
you that I would never ever play that
move and that's probably why I'm pretty
much an inactive player I would take
with the night I see the vici 6 pawn I
serve on passive and why would you trade
Queens
that pulls my mind I know that it's uh
it's our it's our job to just commentate
on the chest but you're not wrong the
engine eval agreed with you the Queen
takes although it strongly also
suggested that LaVon sugar trade Queen
so right because well it makes a lot of
sense why you take with the night you
don't trade Queens when you have more
space when the opponent's king looks a
little bit weak Queen is offside now
White's getting the attack that we
wanted all along but try black missed
his chance to get the ladies off the
board it's there's an attack but White's
committing White's pieces could I don't
know whether it's the d4 pawn dice I
don't see attack on the king
I see the attack on like the e5 pawn but
otherwise that those pawns on d4 need
for pretty vulnerable to me at the same
time I feel like they're we're pretty
serious commitment maybe just take on
you for and park that night on f5 or put
a rook on in d5 but you can take maybe I
don't know I'm not I feel like I know
she could have extracted more he's still
on the good side of this but Queen trade
is just the holler to me yeah and I'm
just a surprised that LaVon didn't take
him up on it now White has won that pawn
and yes black can take on ephors you
said and put the knight on in five but
upon as a pawn right in the risk of
taking me for is you open up a media
attacks to the e6 pawn
so I know she's still doing well but for
sure you can say that LaVon is playing
with fire based on some of his decisions
not treating Queens playing a bit more
passively in the opening than were used
to
it's uh it's gonna be tough yeah I was
like I'm looking at rook b3 okay I'm
looking at rook b3 a nice pin okay place
I almost think your move was better
because it made 9h for more of a threat
but what's his idea here he's gonna back
up this night with a move like Knight 7
to g6 are you saying what depends where
you put your queen okay you put your
queen on e3 because you don't have to I
take on e4 if you put on III
maybe I keep that night there and I
swing my other night over to g6 yeah
after Queen e3 again Ruby 3 might be a
consideration I think he knows he's
worser Danny he's just gonna try to
induce a blender and like he's just he
understands he's worse and he's gonna
try to use some tactics right just you
know not overthinking playing blitz
style I'm down upon I at least need to
play fast rate and give myself a chance
and unfortunately he's not really
playing fast enough right now right with
the means he's looking for something
some tactics here something a bit more
concrete I I don't believe that Danny
cuz the queen is on b8 no matter what
that's that's this is right unless
there's something on that long diagonal
from ba to h2 I might even play rookie
5-year rookie 5 what about Ricky 5 right
now
rookie 5 and you're just going after six
straight up Wow eg I said oh you 6 is
hanging and he's just gonna win a second
pawns position is just busted here who's
c5 yeah talk about just trying to create
complications that's all that's all he's
doing no although that did have one
purpose it guards the e6 palm with the
rook on d6 so now Knight f5 but punished
is gonna be one of the first guys to
wait in line playing Queen e5 yeah after
the next move I didn't know he was a few
plays something like that I'm wrong here
that's
I think Queenie v and Queen g5 are both
possible here yeah but if you're gonna
lose the game move that Queen g5 maybe
recap sticks for g6o Queenie for alright
playing it cool plane it cool which from
a practical point of view is is maybe
smart given that LaVon is now getting
under time pressure why change the the
direction of the game right the queen is
queen this a funny for cuz they have
five can't move because each was hanging
right so now six is what he wants to do
I was gonna so I'll just play d5 just d5
yeah keep your pawn while you can like
this ooh
does he miss route 66 no I guess you can
just playing it on each has his way of
converting and that's that's gonna be a
bit less confrontational AHA but I think
there's no C 3 is there nice III you
could take on control check okay I can
take on D
well 93 I can also take 95 okay so he
just moves the rook to a safe square
still should be enough to win here LaVon
now under 10 seconds
Anish could have spent a bit more time
before that last Thunder I mean he's up
so much on time here right it's though
still in good shape but unnecessary
every pawn matters g3 can you get away
the g3 Vinci 4 well I almost wanted she
for to trade on a fate but okay
irrelevant who just wins the piece but
g4 also also working on right easy
to play there you go right easy to pick
between wins when you're in position
like that Anisha calm relaxed and gets
gets the first victory we've had the
match so far yeah it's um you know it
doesn't feel like beasts in the first
two games it doesn't feel like he's
winning the match but he held those he
drew them in the end and he and he won
his first really good position there so
that's a very very efficient way of
doing things Dutch efficiency their
whole thing and then converting your
your rare good positions but despite
being worse than the Petroff he's saying
he's willing to play this line again
against LaVon it's gonna have a
different line this time though right
because white has played h3 early to
prevent the Bishop to g4 so we're not
going to get the the
double Poland versus bishop here dynamic
in this one yeah and I might say
something about how LaVon evaluated the
previous game yes I have the initiative
but I don't need to accept those double
bonds I can maybe come out and put the
same sort of initiative on the Kings
side without structurally messing up my
pawn shame yeah actually I used two
double pawns but these are just
different types of double different
types much better so I was wrong we will
have a bishop pair versus double pawns
imbalance I don't entirely understand
why I need to see a Stickley give away
the bishop pair yeah I don't understand
why I think he can stop maybe he's
confident in his defense
maybe queenie one right now maybe you're
just saying that bishops aren't that
strong but just I'm a bishop guy hey
we're both bishop guys that's the
problem with people with the petrov
there they're very good at defending
right pretty much everything I mean that
comes with the opening if you've
mastered the the petrov then you've
played plenty of tough positions and and
this is not the end of the world there's
your pawn structures fine you're not
gonna get made it here it's pretty
stress-free
well regardless of your and my feelings
about the bishop pair you said anisha's
is a Petroff expert right been playing
it forever so maybe there's just
something about this dynamic where you
have the two knights and okay now only
one but you have the Knights nicely
placed and he just understands from
experience that the Knights are flying
here against the bishops right yeah I
mean especially once you've established
the knight on e4 the petrova that being
the only open file it feels like just I
personally hate playing against this it
just feels like I just never get enough
winning chances as white yeah these guys
turd Queens a bit faster than you and I
yeah but that's okay I think for the
audience we should get accustomed to
some some any games here yes look a
little weird endgame the Knights gonna
go to c4 white can blocky that pawn the
Knight has squares like d6 the dark
White's got some dark squares to to chew
on yeah as for us for black the e4 pawn
is a passed pawn but it's gonna take a
while to ideally you'd like it back
by like the f-bomb and right now that's
not really possible with with this one
on g4 so Livan 94 yeah this is three and
like us to deal with the immediate
threat of 96 either either v6 or I'm
thinking maybe rookie 7 tonight I prefer
weather night on g6 definitely need to
find the square moving forward because
e5 was just nothing and right darks
taken Levon definitely has a bit of a
pull here Danny if rookie six night p7
95 yeah even if you don't play rookie
six the night has a safe escape route no
matter what so I can continue playing
tickle yeah 96 Bishop III Plus are we
gonna end up regretting this b-flat move
if white gets a four at some point
prying open the a foil yes I am yes beef
I felt a little bit I mean hard to use
the term careless obviously gearing much
stronger stronger than someone like me
but here comes a four and that's the
that's the other Avenue white needs
I feel like white has a push for free so
yeah
84 that looks good that looks very good
that's right a lot of people making
comments about labonz lights we talked
to him about it before as he said
somebody somebody's got to keep it
classy around here that was it yes yes
yes was making spaghetti and he's being
oh yeah sir I got the Petroff to look at
yeah yeah the one and only hey yes why
did I come for a Petrov you and me you
and me both yes I was just saying up I
hate this position for everyone although
now we're liking white much more with
the a file you like what that's a great
contribution thank you bye everyone -
bye yes sir yeah so you just make it
look like I'm very spoiled
I know it's yes you're making you
spaghetti is he making no spaghetti just
how you like it just flares up with you
straw that's making me hungry now I was
you know it's very good good sauce hello
man well the defense is on again for
Gary for those of you who may just be
joining us we've seen despite a lead in
the match right now for a niche we've
seen him be worse and at least two of
the four games so far right Eric and now
he's gonna be worse in the end game
again for quite some time
White's White's got everything here that
but you know what as a from the
beginning of that position it wasn't
completely equal right yeah we there's
this there's this whites whites pieces
are we're all a little bit better or
they added more of a future I mean even
now yeah the v5 move for sure is
something yeah backing up there but yeah
again I think that just seeing it was
surprising because despite being worse
you still want white to have to work and
prove the advantage right when you play
b5 you're just giving the open lines
that white needs so so now he four is
gonna be a target but at least the
vigilante its freed up a bit I I think
that this is a very tough position to
play for for honest you never want to
play the night X III because I'm not
just a good night against passes Bishop
Wright game the a file is fantastic
White's King is better than blacks King
as a block eater of the past pawn and
also as an attacker of that isolated you
know at that point on you for everything
favors white here and sort of like the
early games is there enough to win but
this is like a one-way street at some
point I'd like to kick away the night
off dv5 it's not quite possible cuz b3 I
can't get in right so that's the that's
that's the lone good part about in
Asia's position the King rook and Bishop
on the back rank but maybe he's on he's
on to your plane here the king is coming
to d2 to protect both c3 injury so that
B 3 and C 4 is possible that's right
that's right
so brookie seven well that's giving up a
pond but he's saying that I have better
chances to hold down better chances down
upon where I know what to do
yeah then playing with pieces and just
being ground down and just lacking space
well we've seen him do it a few times
already again this has unfortunately
been something anisha's had to do
several times but if he does it again
then you know he'll uh he'll be right
about that rook trade and pawn sacrifice
part of having the good right mindset as
a defender right Eric saying this as
someone who is it openly admitting that
he's not great at defense that
recognizing an opportunity to trade one
disadvantage for another but to you know
improve activity or give yourself better
drawing chances in the new setup right
you have to kind of be resourceful in
that sense to be a good defender for
sure no I I understand what honest is
doing I don't necessarily understand
lavon's decision to continuously
I mean he's taking material here but if
he does not win this he's got to be
asking himself am i should should I be
trading off the heavy pieces right these
positions where I'm ahead because the
other alternative wasn't bad just
playing on right as opposed to going
into an endgame I mean yes he feels like
he should win up a pond that's the only
like he just feels like I move upon it's
not a draw let's not upset bishops yet
there's a knight on the board and
parties on both sides but that's what
it's gonna come down to because he he
didn't have to do this if I miss shows
that he's quite comfortable holding
these down upon well don't don't don't
trade unless it's a really good enemy
right and this isn't like amazing you
need to create a passed pawn somewhere
the bishop on d5 is strong you can't go
into the office of Bishop endgame so you
need to somehow get it passed pawn going
yeah but hard to do right blacks pieces
are parts I know my deal the bishops on
d5 the Knights active and what's the
what's the plan I mean your majority is
a three-on-two that's completely
blocking on the lights what the plan is
a passed pawn or to win a pawn like on
the King said the plan is a plan is a
passed pawn and wait what I thought King
g3 nil but g2 is hanging however you're
still right because now Knight f2
night after night of chillin this pawn
is uh but but before we rule out on each
there he's he's a quick guy he might
shuffles king over to be three he might
make a Dutch Dutch sprint over right but
I mean now he for King be before Kennedy
for he's gonna try to penetrate lavon's
King Queen side they're not yet uh okay
wait why not can you for maybe night
I've seen I have six I guess he thought
he would be losing him cheap homes well
now he's down now he's down two pawns
yeah now I think we can officially say
that as you said that our reaction a
chief war was right because it looks
like white does enough to win no we
olive olive ons trusted his technical
skills this match so far that you can
you can take the pawn in cuz we're right
then I I don't play mom if he if he does
it and here he's gonna like put the
bishop on e5 put his King on f3 and play
g4 it's gonna it's gonna start pushing
that past bone and then at some point
maybe pivot and go for like c6 but he's
gonna definitely have to push blacks
active pieces back cuz this is very
annoying to deal with when you're a long
time yep already already allowing a bit
of counter play Bishop Bishop e3 Bishop
d5 check came out for that's very very
keen that Ford you're very safe on the
dark squares and I think Bishop III was
the knight a nice move by white not
moving to be pawn to create a new C pawn
target just sort of sitting tight making
it really hard for black to keep holding
the same position this is this is bad
the King on f4 is a good piece Knight
goes the d3 here this is this one should
be lost maybe 95 97 bring the knight
over you just gotta kicked it
check now your knight guards b2 as well
so you could properly move the bishop
from e3 and then try to try to play b3
so maybe Bishop e7 Bishop h4 and then
some sort of b3 move he's going for a
different approach where he wanted to
put his King on each for a Knight f4
check yeah g5 uh-huh should also be good
the one thing watch up for your time if
you're the Vaughan because you had a
lead but you get down to 210 20 seconds
you sometimes end up making decisions
that lead to any games even if you up a
couple pounds it could be a draw you
start you commit to two trades that you
can't fully calculate right it's gotta
gotta keep up that time time we an
honest though Daniel yeah I mean he's
defense resilient for a guy down to
pawns
yeah just sitting tight trusting in his
light-square blockade now threatening
905 oh did did enter fire because yeah
could he you've done that you want your
turkey what he's winning the bishop oh
my gosh oh shoot under by LaVon oh and
he shakes head right is Robert Fritz
Kowski comes through with the LaVon
double X clams he jinx him shame on you
Robert Fritz Kowski that was a Levon
double question mark emote so you should
king you five king d six king as he is
he barely drawing I don't think he's
drawing he's drawn barely drawing oh oh
Bishop peak c4 on Bishop back D 5 D 5 it
was that was so resilient with the
Bishop takes e4 d 6 isn't still draws oh
wow Anish Anish gives gives a smile
their appropriate smile and Touche I
guess right not not exact if I am LaVon
I'm definitely pissed off yeah that's it
that's a frustrating way to back
yourself into a draw when you almost got
a lost right who knows objectively if we
had time without time pressure maybe
black is winning after winning that
piece but LaVon manages to swindle the
draw well we've been we've been slightly
critical of LaVon in a consistent way
that he traded queens in the petrov
right Eric then he traded rooks there
and given that he was also up on time in
those games like you said he trusting
he's trusting his technical skills but
he's not coming away with the full point
right maybe maybe better to sit tight
and let a niche get himself on her time
pressure then then allowing these major
pieces to be trade it that's true I mean
okay obviously we're
agree with me but III think so I think
on eesh we've seen he plays those
engines really well right yeah like he I
can just as mastered passive or slightly
worse positions he's known as one of the
most all players in the world and and
it's intuitive to him yeah he doesn't
need to calculate he immediately comes
up with pretty good defensive formations
when he's down upon in a that sort of
pawn structure is a bit familiar to a
petrov player right a marshall gambit
player so lavon's decision was fine but
i think you should give a bit more
thought to the alternative salute
- Nucky pieces on the board again
Sonny's people saying only a niche could
be down two pawns then win a piece but
still make the draw so yes people people
make fun of a niche but as Erik is
highlighting the the the pro site of his
reputation I guess for draws is that
he's often holding worst positions and
showing really great defense right and
showing really great technical skills so
say what you want right he's up a point
right now in the match and he hasn't
been able to LaVon hasn't cracked him
yet despite being better in three of the
five games we've seen and these games
are really long putting out by our stat
guy my client of course saying that on
this at this rate they've played such
long games that this is gonna be one of
our one of our least amount of games
played total matches right now seems
that way yeah I'm trying to think who
that would favor but right now the way
it's going on it has to be has to be
happy rezian well LaVon playing the
accelerator dragon I am not used to a
lot of these openings I I have to admit
his previous speech chess match against
Fabio I was watching but once it got
really bloody I I couldn't watch it
entirely hard for everyone to keep
watching that one so I bet I imagine a
bit of a different approach I mean these
these openings he knows I need likes to
play against this he knows that
right you're giving on his space you're
playing playing these systems where the
way to
get an advantage against them is to play
principal chess which I wish is very
comfortable doing it's not like
something irrational or or getting out
of the comfort zone but they're fun
opening so I can I can't
what can I say this is Bishop e5 you try
to provoke a move like out for which
destabilizes this g2 to you for pawn
chain which is very important in terms
of keeping control of your space
advantage and blacks breaks of D 5 would
be 5 or f5 just trying to induce that
for G or even induce G 3G through then
Queen f6 double attack right
onsen f3 so the way he's playing it some
people put accelerated their passive
with it at least LaVon is handling a
passive opening or potentially past
opening in an aggressive manner and I
can respect that see he's getting into
uh Nisha's getting into lanisha's uh
Nisha's guerrilla I guess whatever you
want to say Oh
Bishop takes e4 and he's clearly missed
it well there's Bishop takes c5 what's
when I can take on b1 right yeah yeah I
think we're gonna see like go up the
exchange possibly looks like it I'm just
counting now it looks like that's that's
an exchange it's a healthy exchange
there's one thing yeah if Bishop now
this is this is just a good exchanger
Bishop f5 yep clean and you can't play a
g4 because the pawns pinned otherwise
yes you'd win back a second the the
second piece but well so now I think
what I would do is White is try to
figure out a way to trap that Queen
Danni you're up you're down in exchanges
white that Queen on h2 doesn't have the
way to extract itself right
there's moves like Bishop takes h3 also
being threatened right now so two on
eesh can trap maybe you know I'm
thinking Danni after a fortnight g18 f3
the thing is there's Bishop Bishop
anymore comes to fast or Bishop h4
that's what Bishop h4 is retained here
that's good well if he doesn't succeed
it which doesn't look like it's
happening then this is just game over
right
five and five is coming well this is fun
though you gotta do everything you want
he's 31 or Europe are you ready for
Bishop G 1 this should be 1 and then the
night comes to G 3 at some point right
now right away but ok but as you said I
think it was a clean exchange and
clearly a blunder by Anish that's why
he's all in on this this should be for
check I think for sure oh but that would
actually not be good maybe if Bishop 51
Bishop before shot king of two Queen h1
Knight g3 black still has Bishop h4
right no you're not gonna try that
you're not going to try to trade drop
the Queen right away you're gonna have
to find that so King III what more can
you three here King III
the Queen has to go to h1 black is
threatening Bishop takes this is what a
position yeah I I have a feeling this
does not work for on ish but he's trying
the only thing you can do which is
because he's just down material and his
King is it's gonna get well maybe no you
make a blunder and you have to do your
best have to mix it up right I think
Bishop takes e4 was missed in this
slimmest plan started with h3 and king
of - I see nothing here dining I think
this is just like so this is over Bishop
takes G 2 to 3 yeah you know well there
was a Vaughn the first wins were Aronian
yeah comes in no no I don't want say
shotgun fashion but came in very very
very very quickly right it felt like
that middle game was just starting and
then all of a sudden White was lost
initial has to be kicking himself he
defended some of the hardest positions
you could possibly have and then as
white against an opening like be
accelerated where you're given a lot of
space and opportunity
he just gets made it out of nowhere or
the fact that of nowhere he's got to be
unhappy was just the you know there was
no that that happened so quickly that
happen so quickly so now it's little it
all happened so fast
oh man the train is back back rollin
though tied mash I'm surprised that
LaVon continued
to play this not because his positions
aren't good but just because he's
capable of playing so many lions but we
talked about from a match strategy
perspective maybe loved one likes his
chances as the time controls get faster
and doesn't mind taking time off the
clock
true true so Annie is spoken about LaVon
being a favorite in this match do you
think he's just saying that or do you
think he believes it I you know you can
never tell he was they both sides were
having a lot of fun talking trash we
tried to get them to come and do their
own pregame trash talk but as soon as I
offered that just so everyone knows they
they kind of showed their true colors
that both sides really do want to win
this match and didn't want to talk about
how they prepared beforehand so but they
said they'll have fun after the match
with the interviews so make sure you're
here here for that I don't know I don't
know that Anish really considers himself
an underdog against anybody I think he
has the mentality of a top player like
we see all of them have right but yeah
but I don't think he's full of it when
he says he does think LaVon is probably
the better bullet player so okay but
this this looks like the best petra of
LaVon has gotten so far I mean this this
match so far in terms of the games real
Ivana's white is like some sort of
session on on how to drive down
symmetrical pawn structures right yes
yes you've got or how to bishops are
good but if the side of two bishops has
double ponds right you can consider you
know giving them the bishop pair with
which is which is yeah there's some
general principles there but on issues
one of the few guys I think playing like
this no I agree it feels like well I'm
not pretty and we're both biased and
liking White's position with the bishops
white hasn't gotten the full point yet
but white has been much better from
start to finish
twice I mean now white can poke up both
sides right Eric you have a four at some
point when you need to open the a file
you have g4 on the Kings side well
compared to last game though if four is
gonna be met with b4 cuz that Queen on
that fade is doing absolutely nothing
except controlling this diagonal right
so I think Anna should if I was a good
move block because I nation wanna play
an 84
if not 94 why is what's the bishop doing
on b7 buy and so on pawn chain and and
you're just getting pushed for space
right additional 7 yeah he's rerouting
it because it's just doing nothing just
staring up please
and he's also renewing the thread of 94
right now the Knights projected mmm why
do you for like one sees late night for
trades are good 94 I'm not gonna play
move like g6 yeah yeah so not 94 96 make
a lot of sense here but this position I
can I can live with frowny Sh he's he's
a bit worse but nothing nothing to
consuming last game looked a lot more
comfortable yeah
the last game with the petrov right I
mean obviously last game was more
uncomfortable because he got you know
made it as white but Bishop to c7 okay
rec --tx he's gonna do pawn tix and
bring a knight over to d5 I would I
would love that writing about it he's
thinking about it double-edged right you
give white a particularly fond but yeah
but if you can establish the knight on
d5 yeah well there's a line here 1995
net of six you can't play d5 because
there's Queen c5 Czech winning the
bishop because as white I want to shove
d5 d6 right but if I can't do that and
black gets a net on d5 I like that I
like that push a baby well there's the e
pawn yeah yeah this seems like a nice
transition um Knight f6 put the knight
on d5 then play off six and where's that
knight on e5 coin I love your plan I
love it Knight f6 again key tactic why
can't play d5 yeah
and I'm probably gonna put my Bishop
back on b7 by the way because it has
another future in the see each through
day you know cuz we know why it's gonna
play g4 at some point just restricting
everything and then it's just gonna be
passive so put the bib on b7 defend you
for support your knight on d5 and
prepare the move f6 I was gonna say I
wonder if you even need to move the
bishop on c8 before you go for this idea
of f6 cuz yeah you probably don't and
what idea would be that if this knight
on e5 had to retreat
chief or you might just chop it right
sure that's a good idea actually put the
95 first and then decide what you want
to do you get an f6 Knight of 695 what
am I missing because this is very
natural
what is he worried about 9f City I don't
know did a lot of time on that I think
he's maybe just wondering of LaVon had
like why the LaVon is even allowing it
maybe just double-checking there wasn't
a tactic yeah it was it those moves like
Bishop b6 yard anywhere if you just get
so excited about 95 you run into Bishop
c5 ah it should be six I just moved my
queen to d6 and then I prepare 95 but
one tricky thing would be if black
played 95 right there white does have
your tactic Bishop d6 because of Queen
takes f7 mm-hm that would have been that
would have been nasty so 95 is still
playable because after work takes e4 you
have to move f6 and it's pinned but you
don't need to actually allow that I
think he's just gonna slow play it but
there's always something to consider
that you for is not always vulnerable as
long as the right.this you filed tonight
I'm guessing with Queen e6 he's probably
thinking about ideas like maybe h5 then
play Queen at five and get the Queen's
off and the reason we play it by first
is so that if white did play chief or
you could maybe keep the bishop
protecting the e pawn on that diagonal
mm-hmm and and so LaVon says no no -
Queen a5 no - h5
yes seeing that in some lines his knight
on e5 if it gets booted out by f6 it's
gonna go to g6 and find a path home yeah
f4 because like I don't understand why
not 95 95 next and f6 I mean LaVon has
to prepare for this you play Queen f4 I
have 95 I have 95 yet even now nice is
there some trick on 95 rookie there
memory absolutely I'm gonna prepared
first yeah there's I'm not sure he's
wrong I was just asking because I agree
with you it didn't make sense not to
play 95 rookie for f6 the knight is
pinned
but yeah I'm wondering okay yeah 95 f6
isn't that's wrong because I can't put
the knight on g6 and I'll bring it back
to h4 f4 yep
that's why I need isn't just playing it
right away because he sees the knight on
d5 it looks good yeah and I guess
another playing now that you have the
bishop on this diagonal is to actually
put the bishop on d5 and play Knight h7
in f6 okay he he finally goes from 85
but I was wondering maybe another way to
try to get f6 he wants to play you three
at some point how about now right let's
do it
no yeah you three now I don't want to
take on that five right yeah we don't
want to announce no reason coupons give
the night a square on g4 your true two
as well no a nice consistently under
time pressure in this petrov okay why
can't F six has a very decent position
and that's causing him to think more
yeah I guess you're ringing huh
the dangers are trying to play quality
chess right yes yes
Livan here if he trades the Queen's I
think he's more safe but he wants to
play against tarnish here he's gonna
keep the Queen's on which I don't think
is objectively the best choice in the
worst position because I mean I wanna
play Queen c6 yeah Queen c6 and
generates some threats on the long
squared I know I love like light square
diagonally yep all right
i'm i'm if i was in time I'd trade
queen's play Bishop c8 and then play
move like h5 and try to get in a move
like rookie for those are like that's a
bunch of moves but i'd like to go for
the light square no I like it I
highlighted it on the analysis board
that would be a nice way to try for an
advantage with the Queen's coming off
bishop c8 is still so there's they're
just you know staring contest between
the queens neither side wants to blank i
see that amish may want to trade queens
let's say it's retreat queens but the
bishop on f7 try to get the bishop on h7
to be one diagonal and then you can put
that Bishop on d3 so first Queen f7
Queen f7 there and okay
LaVon wants the bishop coming at f4 and
try to go after the c-3po or or Knight
f4 right first reading off and then you
win you get the the Knights off
also bishops are on and you pick up the
III so Knight f4 is coming at Camp seven
Knight f4 initial needs to move here
rook you for rook rookie for I think you
should stop metaphor interesting willing
willing for a night of for to come even
though it looks like a huge trade for
white I I don't understand I don't
understand and don't agree at all and I
think the time pressures a big part of
that decision so take Bishop f4 and
you're at least wrong here yeah
so on each got a long time trying to
play a little too perfect there Danny
and he couldn't hold it together right
so here is gonna be I think he's
probably gonna hold it because he's only
done if he's down upon that seems to be
the comfort zone home yes I was gonna
say yes he's been more comfortable worse
in the ending that he has better but I
think he needed to stop at it for that
really yeah I mean on I was just happy
no I mean obviously it's our job to talk
about the little things and maybe create
a storyline but I don't think we're
stretching or or being overdramatic when
we say that LaVon is a faster player
slightly more trust his intuition a
little more right you talked about a
nice just taking a lot of time there
when
it's just much better and maybe because
of that got under time pressure and then
had to make a trade that you said you
didn't have time to calculate and I
think that I think that's a pretty
insightful comment because if you get
yourself under time pressure you end up
having to just go with those things even
if even if more time would have told you
not to allow something like 904 yeah you
have to make a split-second decision
when our trade is offered LaVon is a
good position here I think you can play
for sacrificed upon great little pantry
for the rook here we go rich or oh very
nice you're actually Brook Bishop b5 you
would sack on b5 in that's right that's
right
check if like one week's game it's yeah
second win in a row don't get made it on
on g6
oh there's rook b6 if root three six
trading Brooks and Queen oh you had to
give a base Wow all right so for he's
got two pawns for the piece not not a
great two ponds yeah and the bishop is
just so perfectly placed already being
protected by the pond I mean this is
okay it's not a technical conversion
yeah that was a nice thread by Aneesh
everyone he was he was maybe gonna take
on d4 with the rook and try to use the C
pawn not sure it was actually a threat
but I mean look at this a pool and you
know the King's gonna tuck itself in on
b3 supporting the a pond and harass nice
move right there
harassing uh only one second though he's
literally living off the increment a3 he
can push no not as good as uh backing up
the rook Wow so so it's winning for
LaVon if he maintains that pawn
otherwise if it just rook and Bishop
innsbruck and I think he might have just
missed repeat chill I think he just
missed roof p2 and winning the a pawn
straight up but still he's got a rook
Chuck should be good enough the king
that King has to run Chuck nobody know
he's gonna win this e4 pawn and the
bishops hanging and he gets a queen oh
my gosh
now you're creaming now your Queen still
not totally out of the woods but the
king at oh no what LaVon had rookie
three there front keep music another way
this is
another way he's gonna cut the King off
shoulders the king and black can never
get back he's gonna lose because of the
Lucena this is technique ladies and
gentlemen if you thought thought you
weren't gonna learn something today you
were wrong
yeah banish plays those items down peace
better than some of us play equal
material yeah yeah
is that a piece in his finding some very
resilient most amazing defense but if
we're looking at the big picture we've
now seen LaVon win two games in a row
the first time either player has done
that in the match right and that was a
game that Geary had no business losing
for the mass majority of it right but
you called it his maybe he doesn't trust
his intuition to the same level that
LaVon does got himself under time
pressure and then paid the price so Wow
people busting out your chest bra emotes
with the LaVon head as they should be
people should go subscribe to Ches bra
right now just for the ability to use
those use those emotes today I got a few
fun ones actually though we have Geary
emote for the anchor tears because he's
been involved a little bit behind you
know he's he's a honorary chess pro yep
and so he's got it well right now he's
down a point lost two in a row and
though this match has been very close
for those almost 4,000 of you that may
have just joined us the overarching
story has been a little bit of a niche
getting under time pressure pretty
consistently and though he defended some
worse endings you can't continuously put
yourself in that position right Eric
it's just so no oh I love on transitions
between stages and stages of the game a
bit faster than I - whether that's like
opening the middle game middle game to
end game rush the batter better to worse
a little bit quicker to the punch he
punishes of the more of a perfectionist
in this format than most players that
make sense but still he's gonna have to
love this a bit more thank you creating
chaos and all the subs we've had today
as well as everybody participating in
the raffle remember if you purchase a
mug in case you don't want to wait to
see if you win the raffle all merch
store purchases on the day of these
events send the price and all cash right
to the players so none to chest calm
goes directly into the players price
fund if you're if you want to have a
like this people like mugs like this
Eric mugs mugs are good I need lots of
mugs because yeah also one of the first
things to break oh not as expensive as
other computer equipment you know the
computer equipment your body so I like
to have mugs it just happened
chess pate went nuts a
million-and-a-half gifted subs everybody
gets better chances in the raffle
courtesy of chess bass she just wants to
prove the raffles not rigged did you see
yesterday oh you didn't see Tuesday's
match so we do this raffle right and a
whole bunch of people register and guess
who wins chess bag that's good I mean
she had a she had a 3% chance along with
everybody else and she wanted people
thought it was rigged it was pretty
funny fueling the conspiracy fueling the
conspiracy chess payroll zone insider
job the chess calm people are winning
the raffles well I hope we've only got
17 minutes left and given the way these
guys have gone I mean okay very unlikely
this is the last game but with the
increment I don't think we're gonna get
more than two games max for sure from
here you know I've told ya sir he joins
a raffle I'll rig it for him to win but
the reason it's a challenge because it
doesn't know how to join a Ralph right
he's not a buck and he saw so I told
them I'll rig it for you but you need to
learn how to do in a raffle right right
I think during the Olympiad I'm gonna
single-handedly when I'm watching yes or
do great commentary you'll be playing
I'm gonna do everything I can to get ya
sir on Twitter it's gonna happen we're
gonna give away whatever it takes
diamond memberships make yessir home
alright well
Anish struggling a little bit
emotionally you can see him shaking his
head right now after losin
and he's also he's also uh I don't know
maybe he's not worse I was looking
initially at the Brooklyn gay - but now
I realize how weak the beef or pawn is
the beef or pawn looks real weak this
looks good for roundish let's say move a
queen c3 Danny I'm gonna play 93 anyways
Bishop d6 is as effective trying to
provoke f3
right you can challenge although
honestly I would play a three I think I
would just just call it you must write
play a three and FF 5 do I throw a 93
first because
the Queen goes to a different square I
can do quintics before defending you for
right so what's I don't understand what
yeah okay no I think your first
instincts were right I think you call a
black stuff f5 is to slow the the white
knight comes to d3 mmhmm and then okay
there's a threat of a four on Queen to
b6 you have this this pin but you could
take f5 e f5 even break the structure
and then take on yes yes you would take
you would take out five babies I don't
like all this pressure on e4 take on
that five okay yeah he doesn't run b4
take on b4 okay instincts first tell us
not to take a five when we have that
pawn chain right but then all of a
sudden you realize that a pawn is a pawn
well well not only that though by taking
any five is a weakness whereas we don't
have anything to worry about anymore
besides the pin but the pin can be
utilized since the e-file is closed so I
see five is now week onion she's gonna
put his Queen on c3 probably targeting
e5 c7 getting out of the way this looks
fantastic this is this is a really good
position because it's harder to mess up
because you know this is a quick
Quincy through getting out the way
hitting everything maybe the night goes
to g4 because that you want if he for
happens the Barclays e4 I'm just gonna
play out for very nice semantics the
ematic transition of the points they're
a good thing to take note of fans is how
quickly eric says that and then they
then you have this week pod and I think
sometimes we forget that we want to keep
tension nice e6 I also like just playing
rook to e1 like you were saying and
White has the pawn and the compensation
here yeah okay Queen d6 was interesting
by the Vaughn though because I think he
wants to play e4 and stop your idea of
f4 okay he doesn't go for him but I
think black is trying for e4 the reason
why Harry pointed that out is because it
makes a lot of sense for black to try to
get rid of his only raise his weakness
on e5 so rook it for probably gonna try
play efore next yep do you double first
and then play before I kind of like your
movie for I mean and now that he stopped
f4 I kind of thought maybe black should
have taken the
opportunity to do it last move but yeah
I'm not sure why I didn't now I'm
getting the impression isn't wants a
double and then play you for right
because otherwise it doesn't make that
much sense although there's the other
move Danny II for and wreckage for
that's what he wants Oh wreckage for out
and then you can pick on you for with
the bishop and you have like a million
threats against the kingside h2 not as
fun as the g-spot but pretty fun the H
spot I I think though the line I just
gave doesn't make sense cuz after you
for you can play you five after wreckage
for but I got excited I love it I'm
excited here comes here comes an attack
out of nowhere that would be the one way
that this position goes wrong for a
niche now now play rook h4 oh I thought
he would play Rakesh foreign pin pin the
night no he's not going for it
h2 though still on the radar
now what
for some reason we seem to have lost my
co-host here not sure what happened
there
flying solo here with everyone
Eric seems to have had some some
connectivity issues right I'm sure he's
going to take his pill forgot to do that
and
the transition sorry balancing Tech and
trying to keep the the chest party going
for everyone the transition is simple so
from that perspective easy or for a
niche to play now that he's under time
pressure but I'm not sure that whites
chances have gotten better comebacks or
both there you are
no worries yeah you're back and I was
just saying that the transition is
simpler so easier for a niche to play
that he's under time pressure but but I
don't know that it really improved his
winning chances all that much we have a
yeah I mean we've had a few situations
where I'm like I like the position with
a lot of pieces on the board but have it
a pawn up in these end games they're not
easy to convert that the defense has
been pretty high level so far from both
players when they're when they're down
upon our verso so this is still a lot of
lot of work I mean just the pure work
endgame here this is winning in a lot of
cases so uh Nisha's going to have to
another brick f3k h2
[Music]
yeah I'm not sure how II trying to get I
mean the c7 you need you need another
bond or you need to get a past fun going
and right now LaVon is super active as
Kings gonna go to h7 okay I'll start off
simple put your King on h2 maybe we're
gonna have to stabilize a little bit
before figuring something out because he
gets too low on time it's gonna be very
hard
changed Sufism
yeah it's got to make some passes but
this is not not easy I mean I'm thinking
maybe queen g4 and recap seven queen g4
and rook F seven if if you can give me
that but it's not gonna not gonna come
easily
I'm not even sure if there's something
like yeah Queen Queen g4 Rock f7
wait a second why did that pawn
well now unleashes up two pawns he's got
a choice try to protect c4 go for the g7
pawn in blitz I think I'm gonna go for
the g7 fine here cuz I I'd rather go on
the offensive
we're kept seven Queen D for defending
g7 while still attacking the c4d five
pawns
Oh excellent move rook takes e4 Queen a5
check leads to made in - yeah but he's
healing it made it himself
Yeah right that's right g5 can be played
cos upon spent Danny so know that's key
we need one g3 the Queen e1 g3 but you
can't play jitta other g5 was possible
so I said yeah that's I thought it's a
good move in is losing but he's got g3
here so there's Queen takes g2 Queen f5
check queen g6 you can trade into that
endgame but maybe the connected passed
pawns are an issue well there's a few
issues here oh I thought Rick c7 I'll
work c7 run into Queen da this this game
has just gotten real messy put us down
to five seconds d6 these Sixers rookie 7
he's gotta watch out for that's where he
played with these six Queen e7 is
winning almost fun
no the rook on e4 is hanging them ah
well Brooke e5
oh yes rook e8 forces the Queen oh my
gosh
mutual swindles look at the time oh 1.1
he literally had someone seconds oh he
pre moved he caught the pre move Danny
Heep removed g6 he's gonna bring the
King down over King yeah amazing
Lamar three love on doing everything he
can did not get out of the checks but
Levon literally living off the increment
you can even lose the jeep pawn here
Danny and be winning with the D pawn so
at some point he may have to make that
choice but he's gonna force Levon to and
continue checking and finding the right
squares but until then
I mean you can give up the Jeep on and
still you don't risk anything you
definitely can't repeat moves here I
think I need she's just building a time
bank otherwise I don't know why
Queeny for Queen huh King up yeah there
we go
here comes the March you get it he's
gonna get in
well Queen e7 check you're not gonna get
in now
Queen c4 there we go Queen c5 and now
you can come in u5 or f5 then e six Wow
amazing
LaVon yeah and we show you a little bit
a little bit of tech here everybody so
we didn't quite to have the players on
camera there my apologies
well I think the game was pretty
distracting in that one we the plays
were a long time yeah that was uh I
don't know if you caught the the smile
by Aneesh and the frustration
frustration by the one but okay we'll
get them back on camera momentarily
I think it's my bad on the tech because
I cut in and out we had a brief little
hey that happens don't worry about it
right now all that matters is everyone
sees everything that matters it's a
level match it's a level image recovered
after losing two in a row he almost lost
three in a row there right right
I mean he's King I don't know what that
goes all calculated it was intuition
which is totally fine but that that King
March was almost backfired when he got
his Queen pin the that was pretty clutch
again look at this pawn structure now
this is funky because white doesn't have
the bishop pair its Kings looking real
weak night each five night f4 it makes
me woo night aged five night at four put
my queen on g5 it might not happen right
away but this is a much worse version
for the bond than before Danny does not
the bishop air and he doesn't have the
e5 square to Parker's pieces yeah it
seems like it lost a bit of a tilt game
right now I mean from the perspective
Queen d7 queen bee queen bee 553 Danny
Queen d7 is that the idea and I know
it's it's it's too early to to claim
that it would be I guess slightly unfair
but would you say that seems possible
that Leblon just frustrated from that
last loss just getting a bad opening
here it's possible I mean here he's he's
by no means pushing for anything more
than equality and based on the speed of
the players this one might actually end
up peaceful pretty quickly but one thing
I'm noticing is no matter what the
position is like we're getting along
games right I mean but there's look I
assume you know we're still tracking
like this is these these games are
really long
yep and with only four minutes left a
pretty good chance that this will be the
last game short of a blunder here
quickly but it's definitely instructive
for for players who end up sometimes
with double pawns how do you fix your
pawn structure
look at these rook lifts especially the
rookie three you know all you have to
you know it's not gonna magically happen
you need to you need to do something you
need to provoke your opponent into
undable in your pawns and you
that means putting your pieces on a good
squares like rookie three here where it
challenges the file but it also if it
gets to trade it off it fixes the bond
structure so we're seeing a lot of yeah
double pawns definitely something to be
able to look at there I'm thinking white
knight on g3 is not doing too much so
I'd like to play an 82 net f4 to provoke
black into taking on e3 otherwise I just
don't see what my knight is doing on g3
quite frankly doesn't go to have five h5
e 4 so we're out that Knight to f4 black
wants to maybe improve his pawn
structure and play maybe b5 and Queen c4
at some point
yeah every time White's had every time
the bones had the white pieces we've had
a Petroff here so for those thinking oh
man were they always playing this many
boring openings and lots of end games
yes five out of seven games have been
end games and that suits on ish that
suits on ish it's not that LaVon is
doesn't suit LaVon though but honey
she's happy with that he definitely
can't be complaining and when he's on
the better side of some of these end
games with black well what can we say so
now now we transition a bit black as
double isolated Jude bonds white as
double isolated F bonds black has this
'if I've pushed that's a you can time
properly it depends that's how ambitious
he is in the meantime he's gonna bring
that 97 maybe bring the night at 5 or
Queen to f6 I see one plan that's
ambitious
I put my net on e7 I put my queen on six
I played g5 and I bring my Knight to g6
so that it can access each for f4 yeah
so Knight 96 g5 1997 1965 but I need I
need everything to work for that to
happen if that happens then the Knights
gonna go to h4 and white is gonna be in
trouble so you know what I vote for
Queen f6 g5 97 96 even more now even
more yeah 97 no I mean if this is if you
can interrupt that night on either f4h 4
by any means necessary black has great
chances the longer you take though the
quicker what's gonna be the generate
clean side for example with c4 and a 4
right now Anish up on time though for
the first I mean I'm not sure why he
played b5 because Nancy 4 hits a little
quicker or a 4 that's so he's gonna he's
got something to think about
Knight like c4 c4 a 4 hour
or annoying moves I mean I'd love to
play 97 g5 and I'm gonna really get
something good there but why it's very
quick with beef the c4 hitting B 5 yep
Anish taking his time as soon as I
pointed out he had a time invader she's
proving me wrong and all right gives up
on this idea maybe he wants to go to h5
and some wines but I'm guessing that I
know B there's an opportunity now if c4
I could trade off everything and I put
on that on d5 and that's your new rep I
was available as well after 97 here
maybe the reason he put his down on a6
was a queen could never mind to see the
Queen could swing over laterally to b7
right but I'm just yeah g6 is falling
yeah all right well onion should still
saw and you know one benefit about the
knight on f6 denny's the night on g3
moves then you'll put a net h5 right so
he gets a very quick version he doesn't
have to play g5 right he's just gonna
keep the night there defend and in some
ways the night I 6 is just sort of
keeping the night on g3 frozen yes yes
so now King G king f7 now the queen is
free from the fan g6 the Queen can go to
c6 maybe in the future ie 5 is still a
plan that our way to gain some more
space on each is on the better side of
this the net on g3 is just a bad piece
yeah there's just no other way to
describe that you'll you can never do
enough here with white with only Queen I
can put my queen on c6 right now I can
vote we 97 you're gonna do something
with that now you have no other breaks
it's just the first endgame we've seen
where it was words Geary playing for two
results right perhaps maybe yeah well
now Queen 87 check okay Oh at age five
or you five the pencil ambitious he is
looking at age five that's totally fine
honey she's definitely on the better
side yeah I think the Vaughn is just
gonna try to open a seven play tickle
yeah the good thing about Natalie - is
it protects f4 and c3 and Queen e7 is a
very annoying move do you think I need
overlooked this
yes yes it's looking like it how do you
defend it if Quincy ad six is falling no
I don't see a good way to defend this
this is that's a big turnaround that's a
keep on that was the point I could have
gone to you five and taking some
valuable space well time is up maybe
inform the players this is the last five
minute game so after this we will have
three minutes and it only gets more
exciting oh this is frustrating for Anya
she had a good position and he's allowed
this little annoying I mean he didn't
have to allow Cooney 7 he could put his
King on that fate and it's not like
White has a way to force the g7 square
you know I mean if black played just
King f8 right what's best choices to
repeat moves and even then black could
even to put the King on f6 King g8 the
worst move out of them all the net only
two nicely covers f4 in c3 Mina's gonna
pick up the e6 pawn and was it
interesting this is back to his favorite
position then he down upon exactly and I
was gonna say it's almost an instinctive
decision that someone gives you check he
instantly thinks okay I'm gonna run my
king where I know it can hide on the H
file from checks but just a very poor
judgment over the fact that the king was
needed not to hide but to actually
defend the e7 square there's some funky
moves here like King h7 Queen takes c6
Queen takes c3 trying to utilize this
night at forecheck idea but white can
like avoid it or just not take the bait
and still be on the bottom so just watch
out we gotta quit on you 6 and the King
on sheet 2
yeah Knight f4 is it gonna so what I'm
saying is on e SH might try to play like
Queen b5 frighten this Queen Tim g5
right yeah okay so doesn't quite work
because those can have one but okay
probably a niche should still be able to
hold but like you said where he's right
back where's the pasta refused to and
now he's the one down on time he's down
time
I would not want to be white here I'm in
black here I think I think all right at
least the puppy on the same side now
Queenie five and then he's gonna try to
play h5 or f4 f5 which one is gonna do
King g3 you could consider h5 or F for I
mean you I think I feel like f4 makes
more sense yeah I mean I can trade the F
for the Jeep on probably slightly better
for our missions gonna play maybe King
to Deesa Queen to d7 so he settles on
allowing black ton double the G pawns I
see Niihau serene in the chat there
Danny the top under-14 player in the
world I'm saying Anish will defend this
definitively well he's probably right
it's on the same side and and Aisha is
shown he's defended much much harder
positions than this me hell if you're
watching your what if you're watching
the show you got to reach out to us so
we can update your title to GM so I get
maybe he likes sandbag exactly people
underestimate him with yeah yeah he
likes to say he likes to sandbag the
title yes yes f4 King f3
19:03 or a queen of 5 check first
decisions
mm five five King age six can you trade
Queens
I guess the Queen and King a name is not
enough Queen age through just trade
everything put your king yep like black
is holding coz essential oh he's gonna
go for it I'm trying to stand it and
game here because huh
yeah let's check out the that's why I
say something stupid I'm trying to
calculate grade King f3 King f3 Oh f3
yeah Nisha's shaking his head so you
know what he's gonna do is he's gonna
play King King g3 if g6 I play out 5
uh-huh now I play King before and I play
out 5 now this is just good no matter
what I can sack the pawn Danni and I can
use this as well
yeah resilience hmm surprising to see
him resigned so quickly there I guess he
just knew he had what he said he was
shaking his head and he yeah this is a
very this is a loss yeah I mean I would
be nice for him to play on for the
audience but you're gonna get in
opposition
yeah to show it real quick obviously
after King g5 king f7 may be black for I
can play f4 puts black in Stokes wrong
no way to stop the king from coming to
g6 and eventually f6 yes in the gun
stuff most three forward way and there's
no way to stop them alright well despite
that loss right there uh it's still just
a one game match I guess because of that
loss right there so uh nice Gary and
Levon Aronian will move to the 3-1
segment right when we get back it's a
one game match don't go anywhere we
still have the majority of the show
today for you and I real quick before me
I mean this has been the last couple
games have been really interesting to
see a niche be better up on time but
still find a way to get himself in a
we're sending down on time like your
your your thoughts for a niche if you
were his coach here I'll ask you the
same question I asked Robert what's your
advice for a niche heading into 3-1 well
I mean I've talked about the time I
think he's got to play a bit quicker and
honestly maybe he should be a bit more
ambitious like you've played so many end
games
maybe it's time to change it off I or at
least not be so willing to go into end
games where you're worse right like I
don't know for sure I mean you it's
really some confidence to play tough end
games for two three hours and expect
that to hold them when like when you're
down to ten seconds
I mean you just can't play perfect moves
all the time and and he can't stop that
from happening he is gonna get ground
down a little bit until he's in a time
scramble so I think you should strive
for a bit more coming from the middle
again all right well there's advice from
coach Coach espera to the honorary chefs
prob we'll see if any switches up his
style and tries to be a little more
aggressive in the early stages of the
games we're gonna be right back in about
90 seconds don't go anywhere we'll see
you soon all right and the speeches
championship will be rolling on three
minutes starting here in just a moment
everybody in case you're just joining us
the 2018 speeches championship is in the
quarterfinals that's where we are and
you are currently watching
Anish geary take on our media number one
against touch number one though both we
can move they're competing here they got
to limp yeah they've been very busy day
at 960 I think that speaking about our
nation what he needs to improve he's
he's doing around where it's like
performing at least fairly evenly right
he's down again right now that's not not
not the big issue but it is hard to
relate to some of the positions that is
going into but performance wise and
score wise I mean I think this is he's
not too uncomfortable with with a four
and a half three and a half right in the
five minutes well again it depends on
how both these sides view themselves as
far as the time controls get faster do
they feel more comfortable and more
confident or not Scarlett Evans shout
out to the 3-1 hype I think 3 1 is my
favorite time control 2 of the format I
feel like it's probably just because
that's where most matches are won and
lost not necessarily true obviously
we've had a lot of bullet matches being
the deciders lately but what's your
favorite time control in the format I
like the three to one as well I I'm not
good at one I like pull up I might get
out one minute with one
like an increment and five one can can
be slow I would say it can be slow and
we get these and we get these long long
games but I'm not I don't dislike any of
them yep
I actually but it's funny enough one one
is the one I'd probably dislike the most
cuz I'm just right Harold well it's it's
one of the things that's so interesting
about the format too because so many
people most the time are playing bullet
with sudden death right so to have the
increment is a real game changer all
right three one's my favorite it's three
one is like the Internet's version of 3
2 which is a standard blitz control and
I think it's great it's a good right
balance right now all right well we have
the first time I think we've seen a
position like this we've seen a lot of
repeating symmetrical structures in the
Petroff
but this is uh maybe we have we have we
seen this yet this seems a little more
unique than the others this is a breath
of fresh air yeah is he just gonna more
open be surprising that I mean there's
no there's no reason to repeat for
either side here
yeah you can bring that night over back
to e3 okay here he goes with that idea
maybe even up to d5 if he's lucky maybe
up to d5 and also h4 h5 maybe trip away
at the King said because there's some
tender dark Spurs there yep oddish is
gonna have an opportunity this game to
be a bit more aggressive and we're gonna
see if he maybe make some of those
adjustments that we talked about Queens
you for now well you uh you called it
right no no Queen turrets please Danny
don't Queens really don't do it there's
nothing wrong with it but let's see the
other side let's see the other side of
it yes we want to see that's one said
Queenie's no Queenie six isn't good
because I can trade and play eb-5 oh now
you trade yeah oh okay does the mind
responds I forgot
yeah they hurts me the double isolated
ponds have beena sabina consistent
presence and
smash right the players don't mind the
ugliest pawn structure on earth they
know how to matter they know how to play
it yes to them although in this case a
little bit different than the white side
of the petrol for LaVon has had most
those double pawns or it feels like a
niche should be able to push this one
here yeah
also there's no way to actually target
those those two pawns so they're not
really weaknesses to me and what I think
lavon's gonna do is I actually try to
generate some space in the Queen side
with rookie be a bishop d4 like he's
doing and maybe c5 before and actually
this with the double bonds you could
still say he's doing well it's an ugly
pawn structure but actually it's if I
can target it and there's other places
of play like the Queen side who's to say
that lavon's done not doing good here
look at ABA and start pushing those
Queen side pawns yeah because I'd like
to get my knight and I need to get the
net on g2 into the game maybe III gg4
but even g4 is not stay because there's
gonna be h5 preventing that that L post
so I don't know I the Von can play a c5
b4 here Ricky bieed
lots of exceptions to the rule in chests
and I think this match is a great
example of that if you're only playing
principle we would not have positions
well both sides have had principles
mixed in with with exceptions right
Bishop era for LaVon should be better
but willing to take on the double pawns
to go with it every time c3 Bishop c5
rook b1 c6 Knight e3 try to get that
night over to Geoff young he hit the
weakness this surprises me what's wrong
I was so brookey - he's gonna play right
it right away
LaVon doesn't have any issue finding the
aggressive moves in any sort of given
position King d1 in 92 is what I'm
expecting but the same time Bach has
this idea of 94 and maybe you can get
your night to be - maybe you can put you
have a move like Bishop e3 Bishop e3
could be a trick in some lines oh this
is maybe before seeing a repetition
probably willing to do it
yeah decides there aren't enough winning
chances to justify pushing just by
blacks activity still had those double D
pawns okay back to the pen draw right
back to their comfort zone all right
back to the petro event that's that's a
good result for the vault and drawing
comfortably there and showing no
hesitation and yeah they're taking on
that structure
I mean I think I think on each and his
perspective is as long as he's in the
match he's got an opportunity he's not
gonna regret that
he's not gonna be like oh I shouldn't
have played the petrov if he's if he's
competitive within a game or two going
into the blitz or a bullet I should say
and he's right you're saying no reason
to don't fix it if it ain't broke yet I
guess right I don't think he considers
yeah I think that means right it's just
playing a little bit better but his
opening choices it doesn't come down to
that right no I mean overall I think
we've seen a pretty well-played match by
both sides but I think that from a
stylistic point of view like you said is
just putting yourself in a position
where you're worse down under down on on
the clock that's just caught up with a
niche and you know if you know a few
games so Livan also has no no problem so
[Music]
we we pretty much know that in these
games don't expect anything serious to
happen until the end game the players
aren't gonna don't go for a draw or
anything but it's when they get down to
ten seconds that you know things things
start to go cracks start to appear so
gonna it's fairly symmetrical and and
ina she's gonna play Queen d7 Bishop FA
it's it's a very equal position actually
this is more equal than normal because
there's no double pawns so this one is
the most symmetrical position I think
we've seen today there's no there's no
double pawns anywhere Dani no double
opponents and we're probably not gonna
get although I'll probably be jinxing it
but yeah that's that's a huge huge
change Queen d7 all right he just does
this first a lot of easy options well
maybe because there's no imbalances here
we actually see LaVon down a minute I
was gonna say he's you can take on c4
here if you want to imbalance it but
those hanging pawns can be pretty
effective at restricting blocks
activities so instead Queen d7 Riki and
maybe Queens gonna go to f7 though you'd
love to level but the way to do
five nice and cozy yeah really cute
first initials on the goods on very
comfortable side of equality very
comfortable because lavon's already
taking a bit of a risk pushing that pawn
to c4
now d4 could be a target and some end
games Queen f7 has been a temptation for
a while right now yeah I want you to
either play C 5 or take on d5 but she's
leaving the tension there prefer not to
have yeah if why is he why is he not
doing it obviously you would love to
force a transition like this and play
against the isolated queen pawn on d4
he's thinking about 94-94 possible why
it's gonna play rook e1 probably as soon
as you can and try to simplify if you
play rook e1 that works but there's
always this idea that I take on you one
take on C form play Queen e6 maybe that
no that doesn't work actually the knight
on d6 is pinned because they don't c7 is
hanging right okay ooh b5 another way to
force the trade okay I like that
no now we know why he was thinking if c5
here 94 forcing the trades well I need
to play b5 once and that was a big well
yeah he helped the game but not the best
move this this case is a little
different no black is the the aggressor
and one of the weaknesses you've allowed
to c5 but it's not easy for white to
land any piece there it's a good point
though because it means black should be
careful before playing before because
then you do open 90 or 495 so from a
patient's perspective that's how you
want to play this probably black and
play a6 also wants to put the knight on
e4 what okay right as I say that's not
what you want to do he proves me wrong
and why is that if Knight
yeah well I think he has this move in
mind Queen to b5
oh not anymore mom could have spent a
lot of time on that move he quickly eye
and played g3 giving his King some space
very very practical and I like it I
think I think white white is doing it
yeah what is doing well that King for
black is looking a little weak on the
LightSquared a you know yeah at the d5
pawn I don't know feels feels a bit
easier to play for white for sure maybe
Queen f5 is coming ya know it feels a
little loose for black and as though I
said I assumed I was wrong I actually
don't think I was wrong I don't think
before was the right idea there for free
Gary like should have been a little more
patient now you've got you I mean Black
has lost out on counter play you're
always worried about the c5 square and
here comes Queen up five yeah it's just
whether he's gonna play some like net
age for an f5 you can play Queen at five
I'm gonna play ninety-seven if you yeah
and then you're trading things off so I
roan in I don't think you should try to
trade your day I need people to like
this position and keep the pieces on the
board keep the pieces on the board kenji
295 is okay like it is still a plus the
b4 pawn is gonna be a weakness yeah this
is definitely definitely in the bond
score right now yeah I mean it I think
it's slipped their Knights gonna go to
d4 I love d4 have I told you how much I
love d4 I love it
oh yeah
Knight can move from c7 because d5 is
under fire White's playing for a winner
really really miss played I mean again
anisha's just awkwardly transitioning
from middle game to end game it's
usually not only Eric where we're being
most critical because now he's worse but
also is usually where he's taking the
most time I mean he was up on the clock
and now he's now he's down on the clock
and and worse in the end game yep but at
least he got to trade off the rooks and
remember like I mean if everything was
off the board now then blacks King might
be able to get get to try to stop that C
pawn I guess not quite white has a very
quick - f2 and 3d floor he might be late
now King of Chu
obviously calculating whether he wants
to take the ladies off the board nope
queen of four five seven queenie five is
a good response there but maybe you can
take and play 96 pawn Jesus you'd rather
give up it in pawn live oh I thought I
thought you played d5 first lose R&D for
you good move yep
good move King takes all of a sudden
Amish yeah in this this nine hundred
okay from c7 to c3 here it comes
or each five do keep the pawn or do you
play okay he decides to keep the pawned
maybe seven nine eight seven he's gonna
okay but is it gonna be enough time
scramble black to come all the way back
he's given up on the idea of the night
coming to c3 you know he has this
interesting idea in the future playing
g4 Danny if you repeat you for afternoon
oh and in a Rodian says no yeah Ronan
caught that before it was a possibility
for one move and maybe he missed it
maybe it was there and the reason
everyone is Eric wanted to sacrifice
this to get to Center passed pawns which
may have been the best chances to win if
you were a Giri but we settled on a draw
and we move on still with a one game
lead for Aronian so okay we've seen
we've seen this happen before in regards
to Giri being a little bit better in the
middle game maybe trying too hard not
trusting his intuition enough time
pressure sets in although there he did
turn it around where I don't think he
was worse by the end so yeah okay watch
out for Bishop takes F to fun little
trick and then Queen f6f-5 jinx yeah
Oh deeply should be missed it even
this coinage for but you know out of all
the blunders to make this isn't isn't
the worst right because White has the
bishop here what they should turn Rokon
e7 better development so you know what
I'm always yeah I'm jealous because
there's a lot more space to plunder then
upon but yeah that's that's definitely
wasn't intending any are te already wins
one back
black complaint Knight takes d5 but then
Queen to see for might be a problem
because the Knights Quincy for is the
problem because you trade Queens yeah
the fish dicks I can take p7 and all of
a sudden I've recovered material of the
Bishop Paris okay maybe it was
intentional you know what they're
playing so quickly I don't know what to
believe anymore Danny yeah well they
both fully embraced the faster time
control at this point
Geary you're doing his best to convince
us that that that blunder of Bishop
takes f2 was not one you're playing this
quickly I mean White's better and he's
playing super put this seems like pret
almost yes yes no no speed on that you
know what let's yeah III don't think
that was natty there's some prep behind
yeah something cooked up at home and now
maybe LaVon realizing but he needs to
afraid into a obstacle at Bishop
situation if he could about for Bishop
c4 Bishop d6 you're up upon and you have
a three on one I think I think Aronian
saying I know I'm worse maybe I fell
into some prep by an ocean I'm willing
to willing to go the obstacle Bishop
ending but but this is there is a
potential for to came to pass pawns it's
definitely a bailout but it's harder
than all the other bail outs we've seen
because a three-on-one pawn majority
isn't something we've had very often so
please shut up for Bishop takes c4
pitcher takes d6 I want to play b3 I
want to play seed for don't bring my
rock over
if Amish doesn't do this daddy's gonna
have to oh okay oh this should be three
he's gonna play seats three and work at
e1 and he's still gonna say the bishops
better than night in an endgame that's
even material but I do have an extra
pass phone on the queenside yeah and the
D pawn is fairly weak interesting yeah I
mean that's the evaluation of having the
right piece coordination the rook and
Bishop having the initiative more
important than the material there and I
tend to agree actually I mean this is
this is still good for what yeah
Rick f7n games aren't gonna be pleasant
Rick f7i trade play 51 maybe Rick t5 and
and yeah black spawns are looking really
weak yes I thought it's gonna play see
I'm considering d4 here in Brooke ta
followed by III d4 Bishop takes d4 rook
88 C 3 and then pawn to e3 trying to be
hyperactive right but that probably
isn't enough but that's just a thought
of mine because if you how else to
defend d5 yes you can bring the F
recover I'm gonna play c3 there or I can
consider taking on a 7 do you take on a
7 I think you should well you can those
are some pawns Bishop takes a 7 ok no
Gary uses his second chance around to
play the move you wanted and the biggest
time advantage we've seen for either
player in the 3-1 portion yet really up
on the clock okay now play a 3 patient a
3 or a 4 but yeah a 3 its be right go
forget for okay you might not be more
aggressive I guess given that you do
have intentions of of taking that pawn
at some point yeah and there's no way to
really attack you for cuz rookie 6 I'll
take on d5 and a high rate to to get
that trade hmm okay now he's gonna go
after the b6 square maybe even ideas of
the rook coming there because the trade
would immediately give a passed pawn
yeah though this is definitely very
comfortable in game 4 English livonians
to play bit faster he's not it's not
over anything like that he's got to play
way faster because right now he's making
it too easy for on each to gain a in an
edge on the clock and please could play
and probably should do something like
yet time to get the King in King me to
do you do you journey all the way over
to the Queen side with the King King d7
I wonder if I give a check not
King d7 there's there's also ideas like
seafood before yeah I was gonna say
there's c4 in the air
c4 I like it yes this is the time to
play c4 yeah and you can't play d4
because we take with check and then
eliminate and he finds it Gary finds it
actually this looks like a transition
that will be enough to win the reckoning
just takes and takes d4 that's that's
huge push it back to e3 right or keeping
open even strong even better you can
stronger Africa p8 Bishop d6 you can
block the B file okay Ruby 8 probably
rook D to work through to king c5 King
takes c4 King takes c4 maybe go for the
King side there wonder what is gonna
play here actually he's got a tough
decision but it's got a minute on the
clock
Astra yeah what what is the best what
gives you the best okay
yeah probably play King d4 I'm guessing
because III tried it by rookie - no
kidding d4 for sure I'm surprised you
didn't I can see five down because I
much prefer keeping my seat fun than the
upon ah interesting
okay White's gonna get the e4 pawn but
black has got the more active king and
rook pair you hate having a rook on c2
in a situation like this but if you're
white you're up to pause even during the
movie for Jack yeah II 5 yeah Oh
c5 no time on the clock to defend this
position make well since the Honda right
that's the blender yeah that's gonna be
a win for Gary yeah King e5 can be six
is coming and it's over okay well the
the match is tied yet again don't go
anywhere we may have another thriller
still again for those of you who weren't
here on Tuesday we had a a two-game lead
for Grichuk Eric with five minutes to go
just crazy right that's the kind of
stuff though it's it right you think
it's over two games two games up with
five minutes on the clock and Duda wins
three games in a row to take the match I
lost two games up this year
I know I didn't want to bring that up
but I know I I know firsthand how it
feels right listen speech just I was the
first time it happened then yeah well
the fans got their money's worth
no and it was it was certainly me but at
this point we're headed for another
another thriller it looks like I would
not be surprised if this this match also
comes down to a game or two for either
side something about the momentum - when
one side wins it just like almost wakes
up the other player right and then they
come back and you know this doesn't feel
like the kind of match that's gonna get
away from one of them at this point no
it definitely has the feeling of these
are two very very even players yeah all
right this is finally Danny we have to
make a point
Livan play D for knees are playing a a
funky position for the first time drop
audibly yes is this is what I'm used to
a bit more he's playing you from our tie
now this is a this is something
different my eyes appreciated yeah I do
too right we've had a patch off every
time as Yaser said when he joined why am
I looking at a pet rock but I would not
be I would also not be upset if Levon
transitioned in the faster time controls
to some of his more his more coffeehouse
tricky openings right I definitely I
definitely expect that I mean he hasn't
been getting great positions as white
and that's hard - anyway sunny she's one
of the most well prepared players but
this is at least something you might as
well try and they're quicker time
controls you have more liberties and and
here I think I nation is equalized
partly because you got this nice pawn
structure and that on c3 is a little bit
wonky in front of the pond at the same
time why it's night I need to doesn't
make a good impression where is it going
right so the is aren't coordinator very
well for LaVon but at least all the
pieces are on the board and I was he
really intending a an aggressive rook
shift to the Kings side with this lift
or was he not that's why I'm getting you
know this sounds like him he evolved a
position this is what I like this is
this is
and you you highlighted it well about
the the varus off which is what this is
the night in front of the C pawn is one
of the more dysfunctional parts of
White's position but if black if I can
play things like 91-93 eventually white
kind of writes that wrong and hopefully
switches toward the Kings side but but I
like what anisha's done here Eric
because the fact that he's got his eyes
on this b3 bishop I think makes it even
harder for white to know how to how to
how to write the wrong on the Queen side
how to coordinate the pieces yeah I
can't even sniffing attack here yes well
it's clearly there but I just don't see
I don't see it where where's the Queen
on e1 gonna go to Knight yeah hey that
former Queen III what I want to do is
white is play 91 play c3 and get the
bishop to c2 but I'm never gonna have
time to do that because this knight on
e5 will snatch it up mm-hmm so I I'm
with you I don't I don't I I asked
whether we were gonna see brook h3
because I didn't believe we should but
LaVon is this is a really F for these
going he's committing more and more
resources to this this is but okay this
is not the kind of chess you would you
would teach your student from the
perspective black has no weaknesses so
there's nothing on the Kings side
calling your name that says you know
you're justified in an attack your
Bishop is not involved on B 3 F 4 is a
super committal move as far as the white
squares go so there's just okay and
again I think that objectively probably
computers would say the positions close
to equal but humans look at this and say
what is white doing am i right
absolutely absolutely h6 that's a target
there you go now yeah but maybe Gary
says you know what I'm gonna call your
bluff play Queen of fate or not Bishop
if it yeah well I'll play Queen of fate
here and the Queen affects the wasn't
threatening which would make how once
material honey she's hungry and you ask
me major
I'll check me yeah I was gonna say it
like what if I just take h6 and take
with check uh we're gonna find out LaVon
so the dark squares the barn is counting
on f5 Wow because otherwise it's like
where is the attack Gary calls lavon's
Bluff with this positionally bogus
attack and the bond is all in
you know what I'm gonna have to agree as
long as the king can sidestep over so
Netta for metaphor no this is this is
more dangerous than I'm giving it credit
for I think yeah I mean uh Knight f4
what's the move maybe there's just no
threats and he just needs to not blunder
rook c6 maybe put the bishop on e6 no I
think there is a threat of an under 40 I
mean the simplest one is just to take d5
and then put a piece on the e-file if
you pick on d5 I just take once and play
Bishop e6 there's nine f6 check you got
to be super careful there right sure
sure
well LaVon if he he deserves everything
he gets from this game because he made
it happen
yeah it wasn't it it wasn't an open
invitation for managed it was I know I'm
just barking Thunder strike and then
twist show yeah that's the one I thought
we'd get here comes Knight g8 or even
Queen h4 no I'm gonna run away like a
bandit to see it but so I'm doing a
Mosley's you're missing Queen 64 no he's
got a nice GA check okay okay
Wow well if d5 now there's Queen b6
followed by half for potentially that's
really messy but I'm not sold on the
Von's compensation here I feel like
there may have been chances there I'm
still wondering why he didn't play Queen
h4 you guys a chance to do it okay he
had a chance to do it yeah now now the
Kings gonna gonna run away although if I
was an excellent excellent move Queen
back to page six crop but he can just
take up six yeah yep and now rook t1 do
you take me six you do you run you've
been talking about
no you take you six F rook shark yeah I
think run Forrest run
oh no he's doing it because his back
rank mate right route d3 chiclet oh good
III check Oh Mike he just missed that oh
my gosh
Erie just shook his head we were both
looking at rook do you one check and
then if you take Wow
Giri shakes his head I mean I think he
did everything he needed to do to defend
that position Eric and then just
blundered taking e6 but that's sort of I
mean that's LaVon
he doesn't mind gambling and playing
aggressive people are gonna blunder and
blitz even yep guys like uh neish
and that was a position with all the
pieces on the board not trades I mean
the heavy pieces stayed on so yes I need
blundered yes he's not gonna do that
very often but like I'm gonna do it more
often bullets no matter what that's
right LaVon LaVon provoked that that was
entirely
he played quickly he played confidently
it was a little unclear for sure and
huge blunders are gonna it's yeah I like
that right wowsers wowzers well source
books are nice that's the hole in water
went into the prize fund for that game
remember everybody all bits any merch
purchase stores everything goes all
donations go directly to the players
today thank you books are nice all right
well this isn't gonna be nearly as
dynamic and tricky as the last one green
outfit and trade off another pair of
Brooks but LaVon is feeling it you know
what Danny wants the holes block he
can't he's ready to swing the bat again
and try to hit another another home run
yeah that's white but I draw draw is
black and go nuts with white race he's
gonna draw some energy from that because
that was that was more of what we know
LaVon we know he's capable of those
sorts of games sacrificial letting loose
the rook lift I mean who's gonna play a
book lifter I'm not gonna we were
highlighting everything about that
position that didn't make sense for
white and then he sacks and goes for me
all right
Arnie's punished
willingly very happily entering an
endgame here with more space I'm not a
huge fan of that choice I think he's
better I think he's winning chances but
I'd like to see him try something
different
King up to d4 was also very experienced
you 45 players so yeah names of the bit
less space aren't most frightening thing
lady well if this just sends up I don't
know I don't know how to you you push
this I think likely but then there's no
reason why zhonya's playing so quickly
and treating you know I think sometimes
the rollover you know they're they play
it up with the roll over from the last
game there's definitely a potential
hangover and you know but then I have a
question if on each is okay to draw this
game should he be offering it so he gets
more games in he's just like I think so
sure there's things to think about
or is he waiting for the bond over push
I mean he's still got some opportunity
he might put the night on a three and
play g4 if he wants to be very ambitious
I I'm not used to I used to though
decisive results here when you got top
guys play
then I can come to d4 and possibly into
e6 but I agree it's nothing but
gamesmanship at this plaintiff theories
I've seen some high-level defense this
match and this is a lot easier to defend
in some of those other positions so no
reason not to think that Valen will be
resourceful okay we have a bit of a
structural change maybe they split the
pawns look the pawns problem is without
more pieces it's yeah you know it's
still not no more pieces you're always
you have to live with the reality that
it's closer to a draw right it's not
entirely dropping up very close to draw
no matter how hard you try repeats again
yeah I mean you you don't win these
types of n games without your opponent
cooperating making mistakes that let you
penetrate somehow but I don't I don't
see the long doing though okay now with
d5 at the right moment yeah yeah no time
for move like b5 kings of swings over to
d6 LaVon seems pretty relaxed in his
nightclub studio they're making a trade
defending with black it's a harder
position come to hi we're just like the
flavor we're grasping at straws here
yeah it's a if one King or peace Oh
especially the king of it can penetrate
your either can Cabana to the other side
then you have some action so right now
King d69 well you could go Knight c3
right now daddy then oh okay
93 yeah that's it
what's wrong with 93 and then everything
p5 and threatening King he five king c6
so now we got a ramp up the commentary
you're gonna fit ends up you're gonna
get a bracer whether it's worth anything
or not it's gonna be a race do you know
what I've hypothesized sometimes Danny
that especially in Bloods and stuff
people prefer drawing because even
though everyone feels like they should
draw these positions you know you're
gonna blender like right I know that I
can lose even a good anything more bad
and game right that looks like a dead
draw I'm capable of losing that and by
just akin to a draw I might avoid the
embarrassment how could you lose that
like okay but it still shouldn't be
anything but I draw it here right I mean
White's gonna have to recover Justin I
need to connect Knight takes out four
and King d5 yeah okay and LaVon agrees
the peaceful results that we've all been
waiting for
Gary Gary shrugs it off shake it off
Taylor Swift I thought he was listening
to Nicki Minaj last match that's what he
said right all right we're back to the
veresov this is what we want I think
you're right I think as the time
controls get faster right the the real
plan for the Vaughn's gonna come out
here which is gonna be full of tricky
frankly great openings for blitz right
we saw what happened last game was it a
sound attack not really but Gary blunder
all right but you got the initiative
right which is something Levon should
strive for and and Yap it off and I
think I think I think it's good I think
it's good to keep a leash on his toes
because Enosh is extremely happy playing
the petrov over and over probably for
the rest of his life and yeah good at it
so why not right
whereas LaVon I don't think wants to
play the Petrov over and over
well yeah I feel like LaVon is it a had
a pure place when he gets the play like
this I don't know what's going on this
is totally nuts right these positions
are just right
but even unlike last game here white has
even more of an initiative like you can
give up the exchange in some lands yes
yes give up the exchange completely this
is what you do this is no this is this
is Bishop III give up the exchange full
exchange Bishop III I don't think I need
she's gonna take it but this is a sort
of chess that I think it's a good idea
because LaVon if he's noticed he's
playing a little bit quicker than a
little bit more decisively that Anisha
cost you but there's so many things
happening quickly here for white why can
bring a bishop to the door I want with
ufo-like g4 but maybe I can wait until
Bishop g7 before playing that so what
else can we play 93 95 we 95 bishops
before this is a this is a great
initiative yep this is good stuff Jake
c5 95 maybe 95 there's Queen a5 but then
I guess you just have Bishop d2 and so
what yeah yeah then you're like yeah
then you're in trouble
so there we go looking for something
with 96 and 96
oh he sees it yes I recall I called it
six in Queen d6 made anish oh my god
Anish smiled he smiled
you know how quickly Levon played chief
for there look how focused he is he just
he just brought down the hammer like a
chess gangster and hasn't even smiled
wow wow this is gonna generate energy
from these positions whether it works or
not
he's going to you can imagine all the
moves coming into
that position was just objectively Danny
fantastic comp dad it was such such a
great example of an opening initiative
development gone wrong for black that's
when you sack the exchange positions
like that
Liam chefs calling for the tilt of Geary
I don't think he's on tilt yet I think
until you laugh and shut that off but if
you manage to crack here you deserve to
be leading the match I mean Gary just
trusses offensive instincts and
resources so right now I don't think
Gary is actually gonna change his game
plan until at least the bullet because
if you get made it props props to you
you don't only he doesn't normally get
made it and right not gonna but it's
funny because two of the losses he's had
were just right there was the other loss
he had as white just allowing erroneous
attack to get out of control
well this is why whenever Roni knows
treating I was like that's not gonna
induce a blunder right all right I think
I think whatever it was the break may
have helped him just sort of realize hey
let's stop beating our head against the
the brick wall known as the Petroff
right and let's let's shift gears here a
little bit I'm getting in a second wind
Danny from some of these games because
that last I agree is all wish wish we
could do that to someone sac sac all our
pieces kudos to Geary stop laying it out
for mate by the way
he didn't just resign on 96 he he let
the magical thing happen and he could
have also sacked his queen on f6 by the
way right right so Geary Geary gets full
credit as far as wanting the chess
professionals to to entertain us as fans
let's give Geary some props they're good
dancing partner a good dancing partner
look at you great
hello be symmetrical here this again
last game they made it look like
something happened in game but in the
end it was always always address draw so
I lost game I criticized him for trading
the Queens how about he repeats this
position but doesn't trade the Queens
that's at least a better chance the
problem is though honestly it looks very
used to play for black I put my Queen on
f6 so if you play b4 yeah Queen on f6 I
mission needs to mix it up Danny this is
this I don't even mean go crazy
I just mean just play like another salt
opening just not this LaVon is is way
too comfortable here this is not
pressure yeah I agree and and similar to
how LaVon sort of changed gears just
stopped beating his head against the
Petra off I think here you might want to
consider that he hasn't been gaining a
lot against Levante e45 as you said
LaVon probably has played you know he's
the world's one of the world's leading
just a 45 symmetrical pawn players well
chief was a good restrictive move and
okay 98 no but LaVon yeah
lavon's had all these positions before
what is he gonna do is white Kim G 3 H 4
maybe Ken G 3 h h4 try to gain some more
space
I should pay for that's actually wants
to turn the light script bishops up over
the presence of the Queen's on but I
think it kind of forces some awkwardness
for black to deal with the e-file now
unless he can just play king of thing
okay
I was wrong the King had just come to f8
and then Queen e7 and from that
perspective Bishop a4 seems like a
strange approach what does Gary believe
about this endgame that makes it worth
trying for a win I'm not sure I mean
we're gonna get exactly the structure we
had last game where at some point
White's gonna play b4 and we're gonna
have a three on three on each side of
the board yeah I I don't know the one
thing about this that was an awkward
move though because now if you give Gary
Knight b5 and the night comes in to d4
c6 is a square mm-hmm c6 is gonna you
can't prevent that like that was it
almost inevitable I've thought that the
vanish is trying to gear up to put a
queen on d4 Knight on you for the or do
you think maybe this may be the one
don't you that's why you put the night
there just not before I like your idea
of Queen and Queen to d4 you know it
needs to all be timed properly he's
going to the risk of this is now you
open Knight h5 right away and everything
you know but you're gonna how do you get
another piece on that force so he's
gonna play g5 94 24 you can even get
that for square both less pieces on the
board maybe saying it's okay so 94 24
it's the yeah it's this d4 th a diagonal
you often see this in the Kings Indian
some of the positions where black loses
the feel and care of the shot well
that's a family in Cairo yeah if you
don't have that and you have these weak
squares so Queen d4
yeah Queen q4 is coming and you're right
I was really just I mean it looks weak
and it looks terror what it is but but
where's the where's the beef right for
sure for example if you play Queen d7
I've net a6 check aha I can even
transition to a queen upon endgame
warehouse and pressure it's for now good
thing to keep in mind but there's not
have six check you can you can go for
may not be winning but it's a queen
endgame as opposed to net endgame yeah
with some dynamic chances and only 15
seconds now LaVon has been surprisingly
Lavanya was the faster player in the
five-minute portion for the most part
but he's been the one under time
pressure here in the three-minute
segment so Queen d7 Queen i-5 is what I
want to achieve which is why you play to
be king kg7
yes so how does white keep the pressure
now you'd like to play Queen d4 so to
have the threat of Knight f6 check and
the crowd is going wild and twitch the
hype is real the the kids would say they
were doing the wave they're getting love
it 40 minutes left and everyone's ready
they're ready they're ready time to stop
the openings to do seven Queens here
okay so now take pawn takes Queen at
five I didn't see an improvement King g8
here or Queenie it now this let me think
about this F yeah you really have many
chances here seems unlikely but I guess
you're also playing for the clock you're
playing for the clock but also the black
can trade Queens in situations so you're
still running out of real estate on the
e-file that's a nice move you take you
take with the Queen and hit C so yeah
cuz you also have this you may you may
have missed you on one nil you give it
to one one but there's gonna be
perpetual opportunities no that did this
I'm not I don't know how do you show
yourself in checks here you're so far
away frightened reading yeah
ah no we're just inviting the drawn-out
with Queen decock besides fly up decides
if he wants to draw him up
yep no now that was yeah well the fun
defended well - okay
maintains a two-game lead as we inch our
way closer to the bullet portion you
know it still feels like it's a very
close match and I I said I didn't I
didn't I don't think it's gonna really
get away from either player but the way
LaVon has switch gears right jumped over
to the D for tricky openings maybe that
was the change that we didn't see coming
right because if LaVon repeats this
pattern he's won the last two games with
white and drawn the last two with black
so yeah I mean LaVon could even go back
to you for because he took his winnings
and that's a bit of a cushion yep
well this isn't as obscure of a position
it's a very standard structure and
that's going to serve Anya bit better
he's not gonna get knocked out in in a
minute here this is this is this is
something he's very well - very familiar
with
although queen b5 seems like a monthly
that pretty quickly makes a lot of sense
here
here's awkward oh okay p7 is not hanging
yeah well then Queen takes P seven you
would have 95 right he was trying to
really provoke some sort of Bishop takes
p3 we could take with the age file but I
mean she's like no you're not not
provoking an attack here and now black
can even play c4 and then you don't
always want to release the tension on
the center there but you get to get new
tension with B for coming after c4 so
yeah the question is whether you play h6
first at some point to give your Bishop
a bit of let's keep interesting
transition there I assume he wants
Knight a5 and then quickly put the rook
on the C file and things up his Knight
is a better piece than the bishop with a
close center with the close center you
can definitely play with the night and
it's not easy to generate a diagonal for
that LightSquared Bishop because he 4 is
always weakening the d4 so maybe Queen
b6 and rook c8 this move b3 followed by
Brooke c1 and it's gonna go to d6 I nice
loves Knights on DX like but they for
this is exactly how you change the big
game a5 a5 now but Queen 85 can I get
away with rook b8 and then I then I can
you take me to but I maybe I tuck but I
need for the bishop on b5 yeah yeah tuck
the lady over there on on a6 and
something like a five queen bee 5 and if
repeat I can even play Queen c5 or queen
a6 I'm trying to understand why on each
but Rushton it on c4 it's also surprised
me ya know when I was gonna say it's a
for us exactly how you want to play when
you have the Bishop dynamic versus the
night you got a priori n-- not
anticipated they're interesting I didn't
see that yeah one of those work did we
not see it for a good reason
well F White had a protective tosspot
that makes a lot of sense you can really
push back right lot black screen but
here there's no power so LaVon must have
felt like he was just worse right I
don't see where that comes from
I don't know why he felt I was starting
to like the position after a forward I
think maybe LaVon but that lavon's been
playing fun the last few games I think
maybe he's just feeling the imbalances
yep
maybe he's fleeing to the crowd is LaVon
risking anything because once the kinda
guy that would play to the pieces they
don't need to count pieces they just
count right how effective the pieces are
I have a rook and Bishop against the
Queen
no but this is how you win if your gear
he's doing the right thing trying to
play for h4 and try to poke at this
king's cage over here and see if you can
get him out well yeah they're both
playing for something because Bishop II
it's also about to occur objectively
yeah I mean LaVon died on they got more
than compensation I like this very fire
I mean Robert and I talk a lot about
just the dynamic of how much easier it
is to play with the Queen once you get
under time pressure right even when even
when sometimes objectively even to
Brooks would be better or three pieces
you see a time and time again how hard
it is to play and coordinate the pieces
against the Queen when the time
scrambles on right yeah I mean and
that's my work here if you're if you're
aronia me well this this looks busted
yeah if King takes Queen g1
yeah I I think it's just now this I mean
it was weird because I mean on he should
I could pawn structure why didn't have a
passed pawn so it's really I guess what
we can envision Danny is it on each
didn't come up with h5h for he sort of
would have been paralyzed and passive
right now would have suited LaVon but
there simply was this and there always
was this right from the get-go that
there was a possibility run the H pawn
and that ranges the entire evaluation
yeah awful position and that's so Queen
check on you to give check first before
take the pawn and then you take on f3
and you're all smiles here all smiles in
fact f3 Guards f7 and Bob's your uncle
and you actually have an Uncle Bob right
or is that a mom did no I actually did
well Aman might as well it's a common
name in Canada yeah I did great Uncle
Bob before he passed away yeah this
one's for you great Uncle Bob this one's
for you alright welcome he takes up
three should be good enough although is
he is he worried about the king of pawn
ending I guess
Bishop takes up seven no bishop f7 what
if I play King yeah just move the king
yep King AJ so don't don't take
everything on f7 no yeah we know you
give up b6 but you've got a queen h1
coming and it just you know the chess
gods should smile upon you there's no
way there's no mate with the King on g4
right oh the tempo but is that enough -
no no no no no no that tempo doesn't why
did he do that I'm trying to understand
King age 3 noise huh
he's not intending a queen giving up the
Queen for two rooks chilly analysis
board we go Rodin's going for it he's
going for the mate
Queenie 4 check King h2 no more checks
isn't that game over Danny what did Gary
just do it so that is gay literally just
blundered away the game the rook on a7
covers aged 7 I daddy that's that's
that's uh I wasn't about to say what you
think I was gonna say that was a that
was a shocker
Eric giving playing rook tix he always
had a draw on hand King h8 was was
actually totally fine and of course you
you could have traded on f7 and been in
a draw enjoy ending but Aronian wins
again as white and stretches the lead to
the biggest one we've had for either
player three games he's dropped yuri has
dropped two winning games so far in the
three minute segment I mean that's
literally the difference in the match so
I'm really shocked by that one that one
feels like Gary was beating himself for
sure so well sirs well had a good
position and then he spent a lot of time
he burned the time played very well
hesitantly and and then just blundered
like yeah his blunders have been
game-ending
the chest Broca's muscles come out
though for LaVon yeah we are LaVon is
Chesbrough strong right now I wouldn't
want to deal with LaVon in this sort of
form ya know that's
he's definitely he's definitely getting
a bit stronger as the match goes on and
he seems to be seems to also be getting
a few of the breaks that tend to happen
in this format we well we say chess is
not poker in the sense that there's very
little luck in chess but if there are
trolls that have sometimes a little bit
of you know unique circumstances if
that's what you want to call it blitz
time scrambles sometimes you get a
little bit lucky that that your opponent
maybe beats themselves and that's kind
of what's happening for LaVon here right
but he is making it happen would he have
won that great feat in Sokka scream
I mean Rick I think the quince act was
bad right we both did but right ek but
he came back and he's willing to play
enterprising chest he's pushing the
envelope so without saying is luck but
you can say he's deserving a little bit
I mean right he wouldn't have you know
he's taking some some risks and
annoyingly knowingly doing so and maybe
that's that's today get rewarded for
that all right look you're Amish is
going to try to find an imbalance I'm
thinking F for all night at for now 94
is a good move by the LaVon places
positions all the time yeah again for
you five onion she's going back to that
but like I'm not sure if he's actually
getting good positions he's in I'm not
sure he's getting good positions like
he's getting more space in some of them
but they're fairly dry I'm starting to
question his repeated use of these four
lines because LaVon LaVon LaVon in these
ones he knows what he's doing Geary
asked me before the mass today how I
ever let grish ik moves so far out of
position that we can only see his armpit
and he said well at least with cameras
in front of you that doesn't happen but
I think I think LaVon might be trying to
prove him wrong and he's going shifting
slowly off-camera lifting his arms up so
we may we may indeed get a view of
lavon's armpit like we did with Chris
Rick before before the day is done this
looks fun for black it does I love a
five and all the sudden that King on h1
feeling the breeze feeling the breeze
here comes the lady to h4 okay yeah I
think you need to simplify so you don't
get made it but certainly
the wait but okay I guess I shouldn't
over exaggerate right me the black king
also potentially has problems as this
one opens up I'm not the queen is the
only piece I can dress I mean Queen the
Queen f3 or queen d3 you get the Queen
on the h1 to a diagonal you cover most
of the checks also a for you trying to
convey 501 B file by threatening I mean
it could be a plus I feel like this is
okay for any SH please gonna have to
bail out into an end game pretty quickly
so maybe queen g4 yep maybe couldn't you
choose a bit passive because the bond is
gonna be very quick to try to like get a
jet get a rook on edge for that we're
gonna have h6
with the Brooklyn so queen g4 and then
meeting Queen D file check with Queen G
- I'm looking to trade things off right
away Queen takes pawn what's going on
here
Queen takes pawn check yeah followed by
rook yeah I was gonna say rook up six
there's no check but rook out five you
allow Queen e6 but maybe it doesn't
matter
rook at five you I can also play Queen G
- yeah but then I play put my why are
you allowing this I don't know at all in
fact yeah we - Queen eight six and how
do I stop rook c5 I can also just trade
Quinn's and be up a pawn in the rook
endgame not that it's the best situation
but Aisha is definitely not yeah and
he's down on time here - I mean this
Isaac again this has the feel of a
hangover game right really really worked
hard to lose a winning plan or he's
gonna play out for here but that's if
not this is not what the doctor ordered
after f4 rook either f6 or rook f8 or
taking these in case just up a pawn in
white skinnies is no this is he's losing
the plot here Danny's gonna have to
change things up now there's no more
no it's onion she's gonna have to do
something after this game well lucky for
him he will have likely a break after
this game because there's only three
minutes left in the three minute portion
my everybody after the break we will be
giving away our raffle so if you have
not entered the raffle do so now you've
seen me you've seen me drink it out of
our merch
today but all merch goes to recommend
players price fun this is your last
chance to enter the raffle we will
reveal the winner before starting the
bullet portion so stick around
yeah I think he is gonna assume I take a
big energy energy change for for a Giri
to figure things out in the bullet
portion the only way for this to get
away from LaVon and he's gonna get
pretty ambitious because you see signage
King he's up a pond at the same time
though blacks position is still very
loose Kingsley awnser loose all right
you could blunder in some cases have to
be a little alert as long as he's not
overly ambitious and he just maintains
this as a to result game okay no he gets
the Queen's off which I think I think
helps Gary right because his King was
still a little more worrisome
you mean Queen e6 check yeah yeah I mean
that's definitely result that I think
Aronian doesn't mind either because he's
if it's two results up three games
heading into the bullet I think he's
very happy with yeah agree if I asked
him if he would take a three game lead
another bullet
I mean clearly right those of you trying
to enter the raffle at the chest EBG I
apologize it is a H which only raffle
but who knows maybe we'll be adding some
special stuff here at some point in the
chess TV chat just saying but sorry
about that
okay the King has to free the rook by
getting to d2 but now this is an easy to
result game for 411 probably probably
just one yeah I mean no this is Brooke
is perfectly placed on c3 this is a very
nice construction the king will the king
will inch its way in I think Geary will
resign momentarily I'm guessing before
he tries to do everything he can to to
wake up into the bullet portion because
trying to get his pre move game on right
getting this pre move game on now that's
what he's doing get the nerves out what
exactly is the time situation it looks
like they may actually get another three
mini-games I'm not a hundred percent
sure but I believe it's most likely that
they will have one more 3-minute game
here indeed they do it seems one more
game indeed yeah Danny that's terrible
for for an itch right yep this game does
count the total clock as far as time
remaining in the three-minute portion
remember that's one of the dynamics that
makes this format different I think
Gary's very aware of that and I think he
he's kind of saying I just want to get
to bullet now but but maybe he thought
that if you if he dragged that game out
long enough to mate he'd actually get to
bullet right away but but alas Livan
mates him too fast now this is running
late this this match is getting it's
it's running away from an ish and I
think he was he's mentally ready to play
the bullet yeah but he needs a whole
year he needs to hold this his plays
dropped off he's a very solid player and
some of his losses were just there I
mean there were losses of you know but
now now you're starting to see it get
out of hand and I think he needs a win
just was confidence I think I think this
is gonna slide away real quickly I mean
when he was playing against Banjara he
at least was leading most the match
right yep playing from behind coming
back really really takes an extra little
push there and you need something to
keep you going keep keep your head at me
yeah you need a UH you need a manager
yeah you need a big win here you need
you need something to go your way I mean
on each one against the Slav early in
the v one portion his first when he's
playing you for and he's just not
getting anything I don't know I don't
know why like it's not anybody's getting
good positions in this case it was like
like what's going on I mean you played D
for the long play to check Benoni what's
wrong with that you know III you're
making a great point I think it's
something we have to address with them
and quite often when we ask questions
like that we get disagreements from the
players right after the match because
it's understandable but I agree if the
two of the best games he's had his wife
were were d4 games not e4 so so what
made him change his mind
huh shoutout to uh solafeet a they're
getting a mug donating to the prize fund
for the players with that mug all right
LaVon is again in the driver's seat here
a little bit better as white and happily
gonna just kind of milk this one out
here before we head into the bullet yeah
LaVon wants that H file open especially
after on each took and open up his own
age file so he's gonna try his best to
provoke bishop takes G through that
might entail Queen b5 Queen to c6 I like
it super awesome Elvis done it and he's
done it yeah he does why he really wants
at each file and he's inviting Bishop
before check if it happens he's just
gonna play kini to King you two is gonna
yeah that's also that's also yeah
Queen c6 I want to play King into I'm
gonna put my own apartment Queen on c6
right now Queen c6 Quincy soos yep
you're gonna make me take on g3 oh but
uh no I don't that's that's that's not
good then Ronan's having more fun okay a
fire funds
can you - yeah Ronia this is Ono Aronian
is capable of doing and whether it pays
off or not he finds a lot of resources
in these positions he enjoys playing
them and maybe it was the right timing
he ground down Gary a bit in the petrov
without winning games and and now that
they're playing these designs punishes a
bit more he's in worse shape than he
would have been in the very beginning
right match shred if you this is nice
this is nice you can't trade rooks I
mean Rick c8 the Queen will give itself
away for the two rooks easily here
otherwise the white as the see follow it
as the h-file not a fantastic position
but a slight preference for for Aronian
here and even as king in the center or
something I'm happy about yep now he's
trying to chip away at a five if you
take on g4 I can play Queen he foreign
some variations targeting h7 his king by
the way can we need for candy three so
the d5 stops Queenie four but you had to
okay so this is fairly symmetrical
Queen c2 I missed that and so did on
eesh
yeah cuz now you're allowing Queen check
and you might not get made it but it
wasn't your intention to allow it if
rook f8 now Queen h7 checking f7 rook
takes f6 wins yeah already already take
on f6 when the Kings on f7 the point is
this isn't this is dicey already all
this is already this is a free attack to
LaVon he's getting attacking chances and
look at the time Queen f7 probably the
best chance to run the King to e7
allowing you to take back on f6 we have
fallen if you had to that's a good move
I'm thinking about Queen shot King f8
and then pausing there so not pawn takes
all right I saw this move it I realize
you can't play came to 7 because rook h7
check but if you don't touch your king
white is white threatening that's what I
didn't understand about this
maybe he's saying that I'm not
threatening anything but you can't find
a move for black because you have to
always watch out for my king said
ambitions and I'm gonna go for oh okay
so now he wants to play Queen h1 Queen
h5 I like it
Queen h5 oh this is this is over that's
how quickly it happens that he game over
oh my gosh it only takes it only takes
has been very uncomfortable in in these
positions were a lot Vaughn gets to
attack and it's not totally symmetrical
and there's risks being taken look at
this
Levon Aronian making me eat my word
saying I didn't feel that this was a
match that was gonna get away from
either player but he did something that
he hadn't done all matched to that point
which was completely changed his opening
gears to much more tricky much more
aggressive style chess and no more end
games for a niche and we're seeing that
he doesn't like that Eric but shout out
real quick to the last last few
donations and mug buyers that came in
love your stream thanks for everything
you guys do to promote chest loves us
Eric
Gabriel beat Rose donating for Aronian
love from Sweden so shout out to
everybody and all the support that we
are getting from both chat rooms don't
go anywhere
who knows the bullet is a is a momentum
changer and in about 90 seconds or so
we're gonna announce who the raffle
winner is and we'll see if it's chest
BAE again this time but thanks to
everybody we will be returning in just a
moment and just like that we have a five
game lead for mr. Aronian
my partner here just told me off-camera
that you get the feeling LaVon is in
full Terminator mode what does that mean
it's like when LaVon is attacked like
he's a player who channels a lot of
energy sort of like Kasparov did when he
was playing you know he feels that he's
feeling the attack moves a cycle ascii
and we knew King Nietzsche was the
possibility yep doesn't have to be
played
lavon's in that mood where he's gonna
play King you to he's gonna take take
those moves take those chances he has
follow-ups he has ideas he's generating
lots of ideas he's playing quickly
yep and he senses weakness in his
opponent well I know that you know
there's all kinds of theories and the
illusion of the streak and some people
just you know believe that a lot of that
stuff is not real but I think when you
have a certain type of personality some
players when things are going well they
go really well right and and they
continue to create opportunities and and
sort of like you say they're in the zone
right and it feels like LaVon is one of
those players who can be streaky in the
sense that if it's going well for him he
can find his own and just be super hard
to stop I mean he is creating attacking
chances out of nothing and then getting
blunders and getting help to go with it
right so no all right well we are gonna
be off very very soon here into the
bullet portion we will see if our own
Ian's stampede continues or if Geary can
take advantage of the faster time
control and and find some new momentum
himself here we go
the bullet is on game on as they say
punishes oh well it's back to this
accelerated remember that was the one of
the bonds first wins it was a pretty
quick King side attack I'm sure I
needn't allow that this time but pretty
much Danny I think he's got a I don't
know what he spent doing in the last
three minutes there's a lot of things
you could do but he needs big big
changes yeah you got to completely mix
it up now like you know I'm almost it's
one one time control so you can't go
crazy but I'm getting ready to push
Harry H Vaughn here I'm getting very
Airy queens are coming up but again if
you're Gary you got to do something to
change it up well what Gary is good in
any games but they need to be n games
where he's actually got something and he
wasn't against lavon's at u4 u5 now now
at least there's some more space and it
doesn't look as dull for example he yeah
he's gonna play for you 5 at some moment
five games that he's gonna have to start
getting wins no I mean this would be
this would be the the biggest comeback
we've ever had I believe we had a five
game lead where someone came back and
maybe tied it but still lost but their
biggest lead we ever had overcome and
and and turned around for a win was a
four game deficit in this format so but
okay here why does your whites a little
bit better in the endgame now yeah you
kind of did you have this hyz break you
have five give you five you have options
here and you're up thirty five seconds
you're gonna try to maneuver yourself
around
use your time advantage and bullet and
it's all you got to do is win one game
first right you can't win all five games
at once for you got them in one game
first Oh what like I can't remember the
last time on this wanted game I know
that's how bad it's been this way that's
why I said you gotta win one game first
of your so they broke up for play broke
up for and dirty for and then Bishop h3
yeah yeah Bishop age three I thought was
the plan a while ago there we go this
should f3 maybe rook G 1 G for Brooke G
2 G for instead he's trying to attack on
both sides which takes a bit more effort
but Aronian with only 10 seconds in the
clock is under some pressure there
night comes around F for hitting d5 the
Knights commit yeah this actually been a
very nice is good take King o 95 hitting
some forms yeah fives a problem two and
a five Oh got overextended to take the H
pawn should have should have stayed on
this track bowling it's over winning
just misty seventh that is winning
Aronian is gonna do his best now is
bullet but but he's down a piece no
that's a win for Geary big big big win
that's how you turn things around
I'm calling it early because I ya know
this over LaVon throws in the towel and
if you're looking for a momentum right
if you're looking for a change in the
wind that's what that's what she had to
go for it LaVon goes back to the Petroff
surprising right yeah but you know what
from a match strategy point of view this
is this could create some really long
games mm-hmm
and at this point you know Geary has two
enemies LaVon and the clock I was a
little surprised at how slow LaVon was
that first game he was down 30 seconds
and well I thought that was too much of
a deficit but we'll see this could be
okay if it turns out to be solved but
you know what this is like a great
attacking position for Gary 94 f5 yeah
94 f5 throw the pieces in an ef5 for
Queen b6 if you want planar diagonals
Mindy 6 g3 oh I love the IG 5 95 95 is a
powerful move b6 is good this is a great
position for garnish LaVon has gotten
his work just this is a terrible
position for white at least we're trying
to 6-2 gorgey five and then go back to
your idea of putting the night there
yeah either one it was those four I
wanted to get the and he stops it now
for now that I can come back and
relocate to h5 or some positions though
potentially is hitting c2 you might want
to put that Bishop on
ooh we're back to our usual Danny yeah
yeah lady the isolated pawns in exchange
for the bishop pair you should be sicker
or D for one of the two I'm actually
attempted to play Bishop takes you to
Knight takes e5 okay this also works c2
hanging watch out for that also d4 is a
possibility
ooh Knight takes oh you could have taken
on c5 and played Queen d2 there yeah I
love one missed it
I think instinctively thought he blunted
the pawn well now on mr. Bay 5 oh no no
should be pretty straightforward though
this D pawn it's dirty it is dirty 5
Bishop f5 queen snake you wanted them
rookie to do it no okay but he's got
enough likely still enough given the
White King is so exposed in the Queen's
oh yeah this is this is well Danny if
there's a you're gonna come back from
five you do it right away I mean this is
this is about a powerful a second win in
a row a little bit of a fist pump there
from a nice giri bonds first three games
were horrible it's horrible
first game wasn't horrible by how he
played the time management was
unnecessary this last game he gave on
each such a nice position
yeah no he didn't even didn't even
negotiate for it and now he's changing
it up again with with a weird sort of
Pierce here instead of yeah oh this is
this is nice for what he's gonna Queen
set cast again I'm just I'm surprised by
what's happening here LaVon has been
successful with e5 again c4
he's he won games by switching to d4 and
playing these tricky beerus offs and in
bullet it's like he forgot what got him
here yeah starting at the bottom now we
here and he's forgot about that
no this is Ricky Juan I'm see you yet I
will confirm if the match clock is wrong
I'm not sure it is we started it late
and then it was adjusted but I will I
will confirm a hundred percent if the
magic clock is correct or not
okay on each had I thought a good
opening but now it's getting a bit out
of hand
oh wait a second did LaVon blunder okay
well you know what I'm gonna try to do
play I'm gonna play h3 honestly want to
put my queen on d4 and play g4 at some
moment but d5 is saying for cervix e4
I'm expecting g4g force may be a little
ambitious I'm a little little too
ambitious that e5 what oh you five
meters Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5
that's a huge blunder that non-id force
be honest Meiji 494 is actually four is
a huge threat f6 is pinned
I think Labonte is going down again now
I would almost play Knight g4 instead of
row take c3 oh this is this is uh this
is tough
this is tough even the second game even
the second game is just an example Queen
takes a five here this rook c6 Queen
takes a five Brooke c6 of Queen da truck
d6 or even GG for I mean the rook is
good here oh this is over
geez Queen B five
you can try something
wait a second yep now I'm confused
Anish is rushing what was rushing I
thought why is he playing so quickly
well not only that I mean he's blowing
into the process right here comes what
he's losing sweet mystery oh my gosh
but he got too excited there first of
all oh no that was that's a she said is
a that's a backbreaker you're about to
win your third game in a row on this
comeback train and look at that it woke
up LaVon guess what he's back to the
barracks e6 wins on the spot when the
queen is on a 5 yeah one on the spot and
even and and there were other ways to
play as well that just uh that's okay so
it's not over and he's shown he can win
some games but that's a that's a
back-breaking long I think I think it's
something about a lot of us related to
the adrenaline hit him down and he
played quickly over 35 seconds young
necessary yep no sloppy but that happens
when you're you know you're playing
bullet and get all excited okay this is
one of the games or Aronian started a
streak of successful games with white we
have a similar position on --is--
definitely thought his position was okay
no reason not just get rid of the bishop
early he initiates some trades really
yep and we were critical of the attack
by Levon in that game even though he
went on to win and this is a lot of
hacking chances again that Queen I'm
coming 5a for age five brace yourselves
for an exciting finisher one thing I'm
noticing Danny is on each is quite a bit
faster than Levon and bullet in the
first half of each game down with ten
twenty second weeds before they're out
of the opening sometimes well it's been
important killing him that he's been in
a position to maybe have won the first
three bullet games until he blundered
away that last one three-two-three is
being threatened and you can't defend g7
rook g3
uh Nisha is keeping up the threats to
play against
listen this tricky now rookie three how
do you stop perky three rookies
realizing you have to play okay now he's
gonna play 494 but we're walking out
player two three
richie 394 you have Queen age five right
I worked you three nights apart Queen g7
me yeah kidding um what am I missing
what was just completely winning there
I'm not gonna sleep over that one I'm
not gonna sleep over that one yeah I
think he's he's getting it anyway yes
punished is that's not supposed to
happen he's getting killed and objecting
you know he might have to switch his
opening cuz you know his positions are
okay he cannot keep up with LaVon when
they have a minute on the clock LaVon
finds attacking moves very quickly I
nice doesn't find the defense it moves
very quickly what you just might have to
avoid that that's that's nasty well uh I
can confirm now that the the official
clock is correct although we're seeing
weird things with the clock there we go
finally the official clock is correct
and you know within within a second or
two so we apologize for for some of the
confusion there but but we're good and
congratulations to our raffle winner
forgot to announce that we were so busy
jumping into the bullet portion but
thank you for everyone to everyone
through late every streaming every sex
act exchange now he's gonna play off
three himself or at some point is gonna
play after a night she forced and run
the king over to the Queen side if he
feels like it's getting a little too hot
I mean she's gonna prepare the King
sprint Bishop takes Ben H bond Oh
Knight takes h3 there's some
compositions where the bond is six g4
and bring the knight over to g5 or even
Knight takes and Queens works it's
disgrace this is slightly faster yes
science wow Aronian is has recovered and
yes it's weird again I know there's the
illusion of the streak and statisticians
would say that but Geary wins two games
in a row everything going his way to win
the third game and and he beats himself
essentially and it's been nothing but a
momentum shift after that I think I mean
you just can't handle these these
positions he just can't handle yep
well erroneous these are quick brutal
losses I can't imagine how that you know
feels like Aronian is one of those guys
who can really stack up those win yes
well and he did that everyone knows that
the reason he's here is because he beat
Fabio Caruana by one of our biggest
margins ever 14 games
so he's capable of getting hot and and
winning the type of games that seem to
really bother his opponents too and you
just see it from a practical perspective
garius is really struggling to find
himself Bishop e5 proficiency through
don't trade pieces if you're LaVon you
know you generated an attack you
generate some speed okay honey
Oh exactly X oh it hurts so bad so bad
the rout is on on the grimace the
grimace is real I wasn't I'm not even
looking for tactics right now now I'm
totally and finally done tech
troubleshooting trying to make sure the
show maintains itself but that was just
bananas rook takes c6 like rook 66 is
the move if you get all of us some time
to find we'll find it right lavon's
finding every move quickly he's feeling
the positions and you just can't stop
him right now yeah so just don't let him
I think I saw a small grimace by Geary
after he played g6 like he saw Brooke
takes c6 coming so well he was
desperately trying to trade pieces off
and I understand why but in that
position that just unfortunately didn't
work out
yep well the the Aronian hype is real
and it i'm not calling it yet because
we've seen a couple games when in a row
but you're getting into mathematical
territory where another
by the lawn and it's it's pretty much
over so which is super disappointing for
a Giri again that the final scoreboard
will be what people remember but we know
that this match was very close
throughout until just just huge momentum
changer from Aronian to start playing
better blitz chess to be honest right
more of a strategy that was about giving
his opponent opportunity to blunder but
it almost comes down to that one game he
won a beautiful game or you will be Gary
but it was a rookie three game that gave
him a win gave him confidence and and
since then that that's been everything
like an assassin yeah he hasn't been
able to handle it was that decision
though to avoid the petrov right yeah
because otherwise they were just trading
drawers and there was a one one-point
game for gave it his best effort right I
mean he hit me three times he kind of
even for I think he was really beating
his head against the wall and said all
right
Anisha I believe you you'll defend the
Petroff and he changed it up again Geary
up on time Eve okay I thought II five
there perhaps but I guess rook c8 would
have been a problem yet Curie's up one
time you can play g3 here as the black
can maintain a knight on c5 upon him
before it's a pretty good setup but I
think you're he's going to put a brick
on YouTube Bishop on and c2 and that
bishops eventually gonna go to be one so
the rook is free to move around
lavon's not trying to allow that so yeah
right now you can but then blocks just
completely okay oh that's a funny 95
lavon's going for more here Danny
Knights are very tricky in bullet right
so he's going for more but he doesn't
really I mean he's not really better
right I mean you got a name giri also
still wanting to play for the win no I
wouldn't I wouldn't say he's he's better
but he's very close to no beef well you
can okay yeah okay yeah yeah I was a
little optimistic and I think so was the
bond here but even now the problem
before stifles the queenside so will
bounce the last chances to hold here I
wish you could have sacked the H pawn to
get the King into everyone - and you -
King do you want to keep d5 okay King f7
for King have six rookies six check here
maybe in the nation five okay please -
fight first
oh very nice getting the rook behind the
pawn but can can go to h6 they can go in
there rook to - oh this is a good
endgame yeah
no Kenny five idea rook to e8 yeah well
we needed that he needed that we maybe
didn't need it depends on which which
side of the fence you're on I am in the
Netherlands though so I can almost hear
Ani screaming yeah from from where I am
so I you know we need some damage
control he needed this one he's gonna
get it but a lot of time coming off the
clock with it
all right well back to the veresov what
is his solution here because he's
repeating and his positions are okay
they look okay we're all like seems fine
for black but they're leading it's not
Lambros middle games for the LaVon I
mean they're leading to some of the yes
most painful losses we've seen well it
would take if the comeback is gonna
happen it's it's now well it actually
starts like five games ago but it's uh
it's still uh now it's thawing out and
but you're right though it's it's just
hard to imagine Geary shifting shifting
things enough here given that he's
getting the same types of positions that
he lost before he's gonna play b5 by
winning and b5 he can place a net on d5
and secure that at Central Square it's a
bit of a slow play but block is very
comfortable here and unlike other games
there's no book on h3 so I needn't go
where he's not he's gonna have
nightmares tonight about a rock on h3
but now I'm in this game because it's
much harder to envision a checkmate here
for four Aronian and what I do see is
that block is fully equalized
challenging the a file got it met nice
that on d5 maybe make some luck for your
king he put another night on c4 but he's
he's doing good here
tough tough for Geary
tough for giri fans yes tougher chess
pay big giri fan we love her
sure she still loves chess pay i mean he
still loves giri but yeah i don't think
her boys moving on right now
95 okay simplifying he's no worse I
think he's been yeah doing well most of
this this game know that our niche is
gonna handle classical position pretty
well he's been getting he's been getting
beaten in dynamic and irrational
positions you know with pieces and not
natural squares so in a position like
this actually even here there's some
danger the Bishop on e5 is exceptionally
dangerous it will look out well you know
what he's not threatening to take trade
bishops cuz there's a rook c8 discover
check I mean actually he's threatening
but why it's not that concerned about it
now you mean this is dangerous
oh this stuff is annoying up White's
gonna drive the H pawn yeah here comes
Harry and then maybe not enough anyway
for white but tough to be black I'm not
so sure I'm not so sure I know you can't
even take on b2 here you're saying you
they might be enough I think white house
some annoying moves with the Queen f4
and Rick c7 right away this is the right
idea by E Reed get domitius we got four
no but this is this is still painful
Danny
Queen Queen d7 I mean yeah you have a h5
is a great move to you just can't allow
each six you might consider taking but
now Queen h5 check I mean Aronian this
has a safe king he has a beep on past
bond outside beep on he doesn't risk
anything yeah the critical in terms of
creating small advantages here driving
the H pawn poking at the right
weaknesses you're right this is this is
textbook stuff and he's initiating this
repeating moves before changing it up
also good practical stuff
he's gonna I was gonna say is he gonna
check again and go Queen h6 but clean h5
first so now he's got to be a little
careful cuz he's pushed it
he's down upon yeah he's pushed it far
enough that okay again
match match situation is really tough
for Gary in games like this yes a lot of
wine coming off the clock Gary asked the
witness he has to punish LaVon for
stalling of it yep blunder day LaVon has
an amazing and an olive on can push
forever and ever and ever and and have
the right to do so
d5 this is this is game over I mean it's
winning for white anyway but you can
take take another two minutes off the
clock here literally I mean you feel
about garnish I do it stinks for him
I'm decks f5 Queen Jake's at five lose
money clean ain't no I think the match
has been closer than the final result
but you know that's what happens either
way I know we're gonna get a great post
match interview from both these players
so as I said in the Geary's last victory
over mob Megara he was the best he is
the best interview in chess but
Aronian might be one who can who could
make me wrong about that so should be
fun
yeah good mouse-kini three package for
first lucky choices good king me three
king of that wait why not can eat three
candy for oh he wants to cut off king
put the king in the d4 yeah
yes I can be 5a March okay looks good
finally gets through in there
here comes the Lucena and it's over
oh is this a three minute game and on
each losses yep
so that's like the worst yep where's for
song though Michael I am calling it
mathematically calling mathematically I
don't think that he's within reach
anymore but I'm really surprised I'm
really surprised by the direction the
match went and I guess I'm I'm I'm not
that surprised that a change in in gears
from Aronian is how he got there really
going for these freaky or openings and I
guess some I don't think it's unfair to
say that we should be a little surprised
I think in each beat himself a few more
times then then he then he should have
been really hard to recover from those
games once he once you beat yourself
once it's uh you have a hangover the
next game and usually play worse alright
well it'll still be really interesting I
think we got to ask Anisha obviously
afterwards why he didn't go into D for
more often especially given his early
success and ask LaVon if that was part
of his plan was to poke at the petrol
for a while but you know ultimately the
the games that got him over the hump
with these very soft sand that was
something he wanted to do
LaVon you're doing he's doing pretty
well with this this opening considering
it's not not usually the best line he's
doing he's getting a net on c5 every
game and I put on a four and I don't
know this this this looks pretty okay to
me I can't complain for a Bullock Ian to
get this position now this rook takes p3
Danny and b33 would have been what an
outright but not but now the bonds just
doing fantastic
he's got a great end game this is
borderline in a game that could bring us
to a close I mean four minutes left
so won't quite be but uh but yeah we are
you know I think what Vaughn's gonna
Renier in the end yeah the winner of
this match is gonna be playing the
winner between Nakamura and mvl and I
think many people feel that it's been a
year of some upsets though but I think a
lot of people feel that Hikaru moves on
against Maxime he's done so twice
already in this event I feel bad for
Maxime he keeps getting paired with
Hikaru side of the bracket something
he's gonna have to do in his career he's
gonna get over the Nakamura home yeah so
investing but if we had a Nakamura
versus Aronian matchup I wouldn't be
upset about that that would be
interesting we haven't seen that happen
yet so I've seen it happen in private
but definitely not in public
yeah all right white uh we're so good
I'm sorry yeah blocks knight on c5 holds
everything together and there's checks
and there's weak bonds all over the
place to worry about Oh yikes Danny easy
peasy from here very difficult to keep
playing late but yeah some impressive
handling by Ronan I have to say yeah you
mean just as far as to his choices I
mean cuz I guess I was critical of Gary
and I going back to d4 but as you said
he's gone back to d4 a few times now and
Aronian has gotten this very very solid
it's it's really an accelerator dragon
transposition but gotten a very very
easy game with on the black side of
these maroc sea lions
alright well another London now this is
not a bad strategy for black and blitz
against the London just offer some
random parting practical tips for our
viewers getting rid of White's
LightSquared Bishop is worth the time
that it takes for this night to pop out
and come back it's it's irritating but
you've really eliminate a lot of the
most dangerous variations when you can
get rid of the LightSquared bishop so
the rook lifts the rook lifts he's gonna
play a quick f6 there I'm guessing we're
cage three f16 h5 h6 f6 yeah that last
draw was our first draw after ten
straight decisive games by the way Eric
so 10 straight decisive games probably
need four mostly for Aronian yes but it
started out with a couple bullet
victories and then I think it was 7 7
wins in a row for a live alone or
something like I knew she even had a
chance to catch up then he right after
winning those two in a row yeah the one
murder would have been a 2 2 game match
so even despite some frustrations he
still had a chance in the final tab
control which is part of the format that
you do have a chance to do behind so
he's got to kick himself because the row
nians been a lot more consistent
Brooksie 6:27 rook c7 rook c7 you gotta
give up the piece here because that
takes you 5 is coming either way and it
seems most likely this will be the last
game wait this looks like something
wrong we may be about to see yeah yeah
Aronian wins this one like he's about to
I was wrong one more game oh the match
score continues to separate make sure
you stick around everybody for right
after the show Alexandra portes we'll be
streaming so for those of you here for
the all-day all-night chess we got
interviews with the players starting in
20 seconds or after this last game and
then Alexandra will be picking up the
mantle after we break things bring
things to a close here well Ronan is
closing out the show yup in his own way
is closer this is uh this is one of the
strongest bullet portions I mean we've
seen a few situations like this it's not
uncommon but on eesh unleashes he's
definitely underperforming in both based
on my prediction I knew Ronan was a
favorite but this is shadow to Diamond
member sloppy aisle who says this is the
first speech as championship match
you've seen life
well welcome welcome to the live party
it's more fun than the replay party
that's true it really is and the
reactions the the engagement between the
players in the audience commentators
audience audience and audience that's
that's worth it I think
all right Anish may get the last one
here looking good I think the players
know that the time is over as well yeah
people saying wheels compressed I don't
I don't
people were saying a few other things
about me during this dream wasn't about
me being depressed but I can I can I can
accept that yeah well they say a lot of
things about ice a lot about both of us
but anyway no this is this has been
great thank you for the turnout
everybody who's been here and we've had
a ton a ton of love a lot of people were
in the raffle a lot of subs a lot of
donations thank you stick around we're
gonna talk to these guys we'll see if
Gary's in a fun light-hearted mood
despite the the result I mean I think
it's the case Savan had more weapons in
his arsenal they were very even he was
up again when they were playing steady
you know control chess but when Ronan
got got his positions and he took some
risks that was that was a gear a setting
that uh neech doesn't have yep you know
I mean and it turned out to be very
important today you need a dynamic of
the match so well and you could see it
was a match that started out according
to our stats favoring Aronian and it got
close there but then Levon like you said
he went into a gear that the gear II
couldn't match I feel like I'm saying
gear and Giri the pawns are not on
purpose I promise but they are happening
time is out this will be the last game
regardless of the results you see seven
clean be seven more precise and stuff
clean be one check queen and another
when well here this will be a win for
Aronian I mean for gear yeah so another
win for Giri so brings the score closer
makes the fans happy and we have we have
our winner we know who was moving on and
we'll be joined now by the players
and it should be here soon LaVon
uh nice can you hear us yep Anish you
there hello hello yeah I'm I'm in yet
well thank you both
super super entertaining match we know
it didn't end the way you probably
wanted Aneesh unless you want it unless
you plan for this I don't know but I
don't think you wait for us
well at some point I just demonstrated
the children exactly the definition of
tilt I mean and I think I had it twice
at some point was there was a streak
Athenian a three-minute portion where
every position I started losing I mean
it was I mean I kept course I played
badly but it was a miracle like any
position was being lost I mean
completely safe on the one you know
where we had this doubled here the
double to f3 of 2.9 to 67 I mean it's
predicted 10 times everything and I
managed to miss the e6 pawn and there
was a queen up position where I also
lost I mean it's also I mean it's
incredible power at some point I was
already think okay maybe let's do the
draw and I was thinking to go to the
polling gear suddenly I saw some ghost
mana gimmicky have three four and
confuse me I thought okay let me draw
this way and suddenly closed checkmate
so yeah that was faced when I was like
how many in a row like four or five in a
row and I never really recovered the
bullet actually went relatively fine for
me but of course I was trading so much
didn't make that well in that third
bullet game after you had won two in a
row and a bit of a momentum changer that
you were also also better their right to
debt yeah yeah that's true yeah okay I
mean very random and I think the one
started playing well at some point at
some point I losing a lot of games
against the court system I think okay I
mean I would it would be of course
winning 13 that would be nice but I'm
not sure it would necessarily make me
come back in the match because electrons
left the Gauss well you just mentioned
lavon's bishop before and the veresov
and and onto you LaVon was that it was
that a pre-meditated strategy that you
were gonna give it give it a try against
the petrov for a while before switching
or did you just at some point gets sick
of trying to beat Anisha in those petrov
sin and decide it was time to switch
yeah at some point I thought it's time
to strike because I mean it was clear to
me that an issue was playing better in
the five-minute face also the bullet
face I mean the bullet face I was kind
of expecting suspecting but in hint hey
surprise yes it was clear that my
strategy wasn't working all day I was up
on I mean I was up in the score but my
play was rather sad they do list so I
thought this time to mix it up because
when the thing is I'm not working the
way you want it even though when you're
leading I think that's it's always a
good time to have this wake up hope this
is this opening you played the the
veresov very tricky is that something
you you I you what you feel is an
effective weapon and blitz in this kind
of format yeah you play they're rarely
against an unexpected opponent I think
that the one played it all so a lot of
times in the previous because some point
I looked at his previous matches he
played a lot of times I'm prepared for
it but I think after c5 the one has been
going D text e5 and d5 mostly rather
than e3 and this is what I was mostly
focused on and I guess if they also had
something prepared but I realized maybe
it was not such a good idea to play what
I want to really play in the in the
quick time control because my real
weapon or something which is very
theoretical and acquired a lot of
memories speaking of back to your point
where you said you taught the kids but
tilt what tilts all about did you how
hard is the hangover effect in the in
this kind of format right where you lose
a game where you feel like you really
beat yourself
and it's just you just can't recover and
do you feel like if there was an
opportunity to maybe you know in another
tournament you might have a rest day
right or you might have an opportunity
to sort of run is that well it's the
problem I think no one really no one is
immune to and everyone I know I mean
even even Magnus goes on on tilt and
it's not that you are you know what
you're experienced you know this can
happen you prepare for this scenarios
so yes you know the slightest loss of
confidence when you start to double
check every movie sort of making it in
one second making it in two seconds
we talked a long time I mean it's all
happens unconscious or subconsciously so
I mean obviously I was trying to get
back but at some point it's become very
very difficult everything started to
collapse Eric any questions I have some
others but I feel like I'm talking all
questions you're asking what's the main
questions I mean I was just gonna ask
garnish about is I mean opening as if he
was pretty comfortable there I thought I
thought in the beginning that match you
were doing pretty well t4 but then we
had a long session of a lot of you know
in 45 and we play the station a few
times that I didn't manage to break
through and I thought in the bullet it's
not a very you it's easy system to play
food black I mean okay I think I was
pressing a little bit but of course my
weapon I guess Berlin actually one
weapon against Berlin that level played
against me in the 11 this system with
Bishop c5 there I had this night a four
creeper which is poses some problems in
practical game and I got slightly better
endgame once and I wasn't actually but
then level switch to this DC we should
defense system which i think is slightly
worse but ok I mean it's a bit too much
to play it every game I mean maybe in
every classical game I will do it but
you know and I should also pretend that
I have a life otherwise play all games
are the same although I'd say this
Malusi think was awesome austrailia I
was resigning there somewhat I started
to make a statement that all the mercy
and get some better polite not sure you
got a net on c5 in most games ok very
often it's it's just doing nothing there
but once a and B points were exchanged
in one game then of course the night of
c5 is a beast and I was lucky there that
I repeated moves but ok I mean at that
stage of course we are not playing for
the match victory the one was already
like 10 games up so in that regard it's
a little bit of a pity I feel that
bullet effect because I think we were
very close in the bullet I mean I was
playing faster
the one was playing better some you know
with whites but I felt I was giving him
even imagine it would have been better
of course if the score would be even and
then we would fight it out and pull it
but I was trading too much and in the
end the one had too much for marginal
well the one speaking of your margin
there you've had it you've had two match
victories now we're sort of a similar
story I get a you found some momentum
and you seemed to switch it to a gear
where you couldn't be stopped is it I
know we Eric and I were talking whether
some players do just play better once
things start going well there's the
statisticians talked about the illusion
of a streak but once you you found your
your rhythm a little bit do you feel
like you find a zone and in our and are
willing to be more aggressive you
started playing there was this great
game of Keaney - and you're attacking
talk a little bit how that once you
start winning is that is that something
you feel like the momentum just carries
you to to better chess I think I mainly
got inspired by the fact that I wasn't
trailing after five-minute session with
many many herbal positions for me and
but seriously bed games so that kind of
limited me and I think that that's very
very inspiring yeah I probably look too
much at himself there I mean I played
also like a genius in the five minute I
think it wasn't really played actually
both quite bad that's also at the score
that's why the score was quite even I
mean one made a lot of bad moves I also
I mean there was a game that I lost
without any without any reason and there
was one game that I won where one could
make me like at some point I had an
extra foam d5c four against two seven
and then at some point I could I was
just getting made it and then he didn't
make me and then it was a queen and game
that I became so there were many many
dubious moments in the five portion if I
mean a portion I think for both I was
not too excited about my played that
stage to be honest yeah well we were
despite the criticism you guys have for
yourselves we were we were duly
entertained and also felt like we were
learning something and speaking of being
entertained I can't let you guys go
without talking a little bit about I
don't even know what the right way to
call it
in regards to your your your Twitter
wars so after your last match an issue
you had the tweet of the cat on the
turtle and then LaVon yeah yeah
respond the one decided it was I mean
the turtle or the cat was him I don't
know he decided to respond to that well
he responded to and through your your
face on his favorite best friend I
believe it was I think more response not
so much to my turtle tweet but at some
point in New Year's I wrote that lavon's
has an account of his dog which I
discovered because I mean I've seen this
account a long time ago but at some
point he posted a picture of his dog in
a you know after marriage and wait
second I've seen this look before if I
try to and then some point later I I saw
this phone chicken through a second
that's a familiar family the name and I
realized that they were actually made an
account of his dog and you have to just
check it out I mean he's been bullying
cyberbullying myself
hikaru Lawrence you know trend all his
best friends were cyber bullied via that
anonymous account and I thought Jesus
Christ
would you really cyber bully someone
from your dog's account well how can I
control him the obviously your dog
panchak who's um God like you said I
guess I guess he's I guess he's good
with it with the computer then if he's
if he's the one behind his own account
so so we have to look for the dog's
Twitter account now I think the dog
should go absolutely wild yes I think
that was more the reference that I feel
the one decided to photoshop me into
into his his dog which that I think had
to do more with that but yeah I think it
is it is fun and as long as we don't
kill each other it's all fine well if
somehow any of the fans here are not
following these two guys on Twitter you
should be to the donut and the dog and
the dog I would say probably the two
most entertaining top chess players on
the planet especially in terms of social
media so we love you guys the fans love
you really and thanks for thanks for
having fun I don't have any other
questions it was it was a great match
obviously before we let
you go we always like to ask how you see
yourself stacking up in the and the
remainder of the events so Livan you've
you've moved on now to the semi-finals
we will have the real Chess Championship
taking place December 1st and 2nd after
this small event in November that some
people know about and you'll be playing
the winner between a carro and MBL what
are your thoughts on I'll ask you this
what are your thoughts on what mvl has
to do to pull the upset what many people
feel is so hard to be here car not come
or in a match like this yes the one
minute session is the hardest any play
against seeker I mean it's hardest for
me I think I'm like kilometers away from
this guy from this guy's I mean I'm
really bad one minute but max is better
than much better than me I'm stupid but
I think Hikaru is is already a different
class
that's what maxim told I wouldn't know I
I don't play bullets I know how bad I am
so I stay away well either way you're
gonna be you're gonna have your chance
to do your best then in pull it when
when you play either one of those guys
for the championship so thank you both
Anish and LaVon and unless you have any
other questions partner I think we'll
sign off and wish them the best I look
forward to seeing on each next year this
year he made it farther and next year
yeah we're slow learner yes we'll give
our best of panchak LaVon
congratulations again the fans the fans
love you guys lots of donations after
your tactics and stuff so increase the
prize fund we chess base very upset the
most well-known chesa philanthropist on
Twitter she's upset you didn't move on
Geary sorry LaVon
she was rooting for a niche I don't I
guess he's I guess he's cute or some so
I don't know but we but good luck good
luck in the next round and thank you
both thank you thank you for you guys
you